and we are live thank you all so much
for being here it is good to be back
with you all this evening I am
particularly excited because we're doing
something I haven't done in a while the
floor will be open to any Seventh Day
Adventist in the world to change our
mind regarding the great controversy
we've done some of these in the past but
we haven't done such on this topic more
specifically though the great
controversy theme or world view the
unique sth Adventist Paradigm that
accompanies 7th Day adventism and cannot
be separated from it as we're about to
see you'll notice I said hour that's
because my friend Mike curn will be with
us tonight to add to the discussion Mike
is a former Seventh Adventist of 43
years and was a lead Elder of an SDA
Church upon his departure but the thesis
of the
night just so it's
clear can any Seventh Day Adventist show
us that the Great controver Y worldview
is supported
strictly from the Bible can any Seventh
Adventist show us that the great
controversy worldview is supported
strictly from the Bible this is where
the rubber meets the road folks there is
no getting around this there is no
divorcing this from the system of
adventism itself they are a package deal
the SDA Church tells us that everything
they believe comes strictly from the
Bible okay so we are eager to have this
explained
to us I also want to remind you all real
quick that if you like what we're doing
here and you'd like to see more of that
meaning the equipping of more Christians
to reach more 7th Day Adventists please
consider partnering with us it is the
support of our partners and YouTube
members that makes this effort uh have
the impact that it does and it really is
a team effort and I'm super grateful for
all of you guys if this is something you
are interested in the link is in the
description box down below but with that
said
Mike how's it going bro man it's much
better now that I'm here here with you
oh well that's the that's the like uh
the Christiane
answer no it's going good here it's a
little cold I mean we're supposed to get
like four inches of snow here yeah we're
supposed to get eight
tonight well so are you trying to double
me I don't understand you always trying
no I guess I think God is because God's
the one that controls that not me so I'm
just the messenger don't shoot the
messenger now folks the link to join
tonight is pinned in the live chat but
please please please only join if you
are a sth day Adventist this is not an
open Q&A we're talking about something
very specific tonight so please only
join if you are in SDA the floor will be
open shortly but first I need to present
the specifics about the objections like
I normally do at these because as we
will see in one of our sources a lot of
people including Seventh Day Adventist
hear great controversy and they think of
Ellen White's book while that is
certainly a part of the whole it isn't
the Crux of the matter now I want to
preface for the Adventist in the
audience before citing any sources I am
citing sources not because every
Adventist in the world is responsible
for the sources cited they demonstrate
that we aren't making stuff up and our
objections are against actual claims
made in official Source documentation
not Fringe Joe Schmo private opinions of
an SDA off in the corner somewhere so we
are going to look at herb Douglas's
article in Ministry magazine on the
subject titled what is the great
controversy theme every time I cite this
I inevitably get lots of Adventists they
email us they comment and complain about
Dr Douglas being an orthodox Adventist
meaning he actually understood the
system of teaching and its
interconnectedness and they don't like
that so that means he stood by the by
the book teaching he understood that you
can't peace meal together your own
flavor of adventism and be consistent I
understand there's people out there that
do that but those people try and dismiss
this as herb Douglas's private opinion
but no all he is doing is putting skin
on the bones of fundamental belief
number eight and he is reiterating what
the fundamental beliefs book puts forth
which I have here so if you want to go
that route tonight happy to go that
route okay furthermore what I'm about to
read was approved and proofread by a
body of people and then formally printed
in an official organ of the organization
not a private blog paper or something
like that okay so let's get into it
here for those that do not not known he
writes
quote some may think of the great
controversy between Christ and Satan the
fifth book in the conflict of the AG
series Others May think of Jeremiah's
announcement that the Lord has a
controversy with the Nations Jeremiah
25:31 a theme that HL Hastings in 1858
emphasized in his book The Great
controversy between God and man its
origin progress and end the Great
controversy theme is more than an
historical survey of the battle between
Christ and Satan as traced through the
events of secular and Biblical history
more than an overview of the cosmic
conflict as unfolded in certain biblical
passages such as Revelation 12 more than
an awareness of that struggle within our
own
lives for seventh day Adventists the
great controversy theme is the core
concept that brings coherence to all
biblical
subjects every philosophical or
theological system Builds on a central
governing theme or Paradigm its central
theme becomes that system's core truth
and determines all of that system's
principles and policies Stephen Hawking
the remarkable Cambridge physicist wrote
in his 1988 book A Brief History of Time
that should scientists discover The
long-sought Theory of Everything to
explain the varying mechanisms of the
universe we should know the mind of
God seventh day Adventists have been
given that a perspective which provides
a theory of everything it introduces us
to the mind of God we didn't Discover it
it was given to us we call it the great
controversy theme so
pause this article is titled what is the
great controversy theme the answer the
answer is then given almost immediately
it isn't simply Ellen White's book nor
the simple awareness of the battle
between good and
evil recently I've had more and more
Adventists try and act like that's all
the great controversy is it's just a
recognition of Good and Evil we've seen
Dr Jud Lake for example give this exact
response to this platform but as Douglas
notes
no that isn't what the real breadth of
the great controversy is it is a theme a
paradigm a worldview that supposedly
brings coherence to all of the
Bible it's the equivalent of what stepen
Hawking referred to as the God particle
only in the theological
realm it introduces us supposedly to the
mind of God and 7th Day Adventist he
says did not discover this it was given
to them okay he
continues how we understand this Core
theme directly affects how we grasp the
intent of the biblical writers when they
used words such as righteousness
salvation gospel Etc the GCT helps us to
work our way through centuy of
theological confusion over the meaning
of such realities as justification
sanctification atonement obedience and
works without the great controversy
theme all would remain divided over such
subjects as the importance of the Old
Testament Sanctuary service and the New
Testament view of Christ as our high
priest mediator the meaning of faith and
Grace the place of obedience in relation
to legalism why Jesus came the first
time why he came the way he did and when
he will return
close quote so this theme which wasn't
discovered but was given to the SDA
Church informs how one understands
virtually all biblical terminology
whether it's atonement Faith gospel
salvation Etc it supposedly provides the
answers that are supposed to clear up
centuries of confusion and without it
all would remain divided over various
theological
matters so the unique possession of this
worldview by the SDA church is supposed
to support their Remnant Doctrine it's
supposed to be part of why they're
completely United in ways that Babylon
isn't AKA Roman Catholics Protestants
Etc but we also see him state that it
informs for SDA theology why Jesus came
the first time why he came the way he
did and when he will return which means
it informs what the cross was supposedly
about what Christ's grave was about what
his Incarnation was about and so on
further further evidencing that this
cannot be divorced from the SDA system
of theology he also
adds quote the Adventist eschatological
framework sets us apart from every other
denomination that speaks of the end of
the world because it is governed by the
GCT the distinctly administ view is
formed by a mutually supportive cluster
of ideas including conditional
immortality 7th Day sabari inis a
premillennial historicist eschatology
acceptance of the gift of Prophecy in
the ministry of Ellen White teachings
about the Priestly work of Christ in the
Heavenly sanctuary and a prepared people
by his grace this mutually supportive
cluster of ideas that marks Adventist
eschatology exists today because the
great controversy theme informs all
areas of Adventist
thought when the controversy is
over the purpose of the Gospel will be
seen as the Vindication of the wisdom
power and love of God close quote so
according to this what sets adventism
apart from everyone else Mike the Great
controversy theme the GC the GCT that's
what it is there you go and Douglas
points out that their doctrines are a
mutually supportive set of
clusters they all support one another
and they're all needed to remain intact
this is why I always say people that
balk and scoff at Douglas do not
understand the necessity of the system
he understood you can't just peac meal
it the whole thing collapses if you do
that he just listed off a bunch of
things that you have to affirm that
support one another which includes by
the way Ellen White but then he gives
the central Crux of the matter he says
when the controversy is
over it will be seen that the purpose of
the Gospel a loaded term in their system
will be the Vindication of God which
begs the question
what does God allegedly need Vindicated
from now we will look at that in a
moment and where that's coming from but
Mike are Douglas's words clear to you or
am I missing something it it's crystal
clear to me I I think he actually is a
great writer I think that he's made his
point very clear and I wish avenus would
probably know this
more absolutely exactly what they
believe they're supposed to believe
anyways and he's not the only one that
says this folks I I mean I just I cite
this Source constantly because it's just
so clear it's just so direct it's so
forthright there's no games there's no
beating around the bush he owned it I
wish he were still alive I'd have him on
here but I'm not sure how if it wasn't
discovered but given to the SDA Church
one can turn around and say it comes
from the Bible especially given what he
says about how it's the lens one must
understand the Bible through but maybe
an Adventist can change our minds on
that but lastly
here five key claims okay
now this is not exhaustive by any means
but the last thing before we bring
somebody on if they show up God being on
trial and needing
Vindicated there are four primary
details or claims from the story line
that in uh that inform and are
Downstream of this Central claim which
is number five that God is on trial and
vindicating himself and Mike and I would
love to see biblical support for them
since the SDA Church tells us that
everything adventism teaches comes
strictly from the Bible okay the first
is that prior to the Earth's
creation Jesus was exalted and given
command that devolved onto him from God
the Father the second is that Lucifer
became jealous of this exaltation began
attacking the Ten Commandments becoming
Satan the accuser claiming that God is
not fair and his law needs changed the
third is that mankind was created in the
controversy already
underway as a part of God's vindicating
himself self before the universe the
fourth is that prior to incarnating as a
man Jesus incarnated as an
angel taking on an Angelic
nature to seek and save Angels
vindicating the character of God on the
plane of
angels and all of these flow Downstream
from what Douglas said the goal of the
Gospel is the Vindication of God which
is that fifth Point Satan's Z
accusations allegedly put God on trial
and now he's vindicating himself and his
law before all watching intelligences
all these other beings on other worlds
and the angels Etc which is what the
ultimate purpose of the Gospel is he
said okay without these fundamental
claims the great controversy theme falls
apart there are numerous others we could
look at but this is just a sampling of
core claims that influence the Seventh
Day Adventist Church's handling and
application of the Bible and lastly I
want to remind seven VST out there what
Ellen White instructed them to
do
quote then Brethren use wisely the
precious light that God has given
presenting it to the people in the
meekness and gentleness of Christ meet
the Prejudice of the people with an
invitation such as Philip gave Nathaniel
come and see say if seventh Adventists
have the truth and can prove it from the
Oracles of God you do not wish to be
found fighting against God we are to be
bodies of light proclaiming Christ and
his love to the people and presenting
all our doctrines in their true relation
to this important
theme we shall have to meet people as
full of hatred to our work as were the
priests and rulers in the days of Christ
to his work it is our duty however to
diffuse light in every direction and lay
out in clear lines what the sinner must
do in order to obtain eternal life close
quote so we would love for any Adventist
in the world to heed this uh divinely
inspired advice step up to the plate and
demonstrate for us that the pre-earth
origin story of the great controversy
which influences in forms all of SDA
theology is biblical because the
organization insists that everything
they teach and believe comes strictly
from the Bible so with that said brother
Mike we have our first person Joseph you
are here sir you're going to want to
unmute your
mic hey excellent how's it going doing
well how are you good so sorry I I just
want to make sure I'm responding to the
correct thing so which element of the
great controversy is it that you
specifically um because obviously you
said it's not the fact that there's the
war you know between God and Satan
generically because all Christians
believe that all Christians believe that
we're talking about specifically the
prear origin story all this information
that is so I'll explain it to you this
way Christians believe in Revelation
from God through scripture and we
believe that that lays out an overview
of Redemptive history the Adventist
Church would agree but they would also
say they have an extra set of
information that other Christians don't
have prior to what is accounted for in
Genesis they have this pre-earth origin
storyline with who knows how long that
period of time was I've seen SDA
covenant theology charts and it's just
question marks because they say it's
unknown but all of that prear
information then in forms later on in
Redemptive history aka the Bible so the
entire prear origin story because for
example the Adventist Church teaches
Jesus went to the cross and the cross
was ultimately about vindicating the law
and God's character from Satan's
accusations so we would love to see
where that is in the Bible that prior to
the Earth's creation Satan began
attacking the Ten Commandments claiming
that God's law is not fair and Angels
need no law over them that sort of
stuff yeah so I mean the two passages
that come to mind um I I know in Isaiah
14 where it talks about I'll bring it up
yeah okay any particular translation or
do you not care I it doesn't matter to
me okay I'm assuming you want to go to
the the king of TI yeah
okay just a second getting it up
here what verse in
particular um let me see sorry
essentially I mean essentially starts at
verse 12 if you're I believe verse 12 um
okay wait
there oh what is it that you still say
in your heart um sorry I'm not actually
in the version that I'm usually oh sorry
I'm in
the Isaiah 14 okay I've got it up on
screen here okay yeah so how you have
fallen from Heaven um right so that's
Lucifer right you know saying right that
he's claiming he's wanting the
attributes of God for himself um and so
that's that's part of where we see that
there's this
backstory um but but real quick where
are all of those details though all this
tells you is that Lucifer which again
we're having to do some sort of of
deduction here to some degree which is
fine but where does it tell you any of
that backstory it just tells you that
Lucifer desired something where are you
getting from this text that all this
other
information um which other information
sorry well you're saying that uh Lucifer
desired the authority of God we would we
would agree that's that's there in the
text but how does that support that what
that looked like was because Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with God the
Father Lucifer became jealous began
attacking the 10 Commandments leading to
God having to hold a council meeting to
figure out this problem and his response
to it and while that was happening
Lucifer was going around to all the
Angels which eventually LED which
there's a bunch of details in between
there but that eventually led to war
breaking out in heaven and Lucifer being
defeated in that first battle and cast
down where where's all those details
from this text oh well yeah no they
wouldn't all be in those texts I mean I
don't think I don't think we can rest
the entire you know great contr Doctrine
just on this text um there's also
Revelation 12 right which talks about
the war in heaven um and then you know
when you when you take various
scriptures right that talk about right
the law of God right the sin being a
transgression of the law right I mean
you've got to take all of scripture and
let scripture interpret itself I was
just yeah but not go ahead sorry so I
was we the thing I was drawing from um
Isaiah 14 is just the fact right where
we see the backstory right we also see
part of the backstory alluded to in job
the early the opening chapter of job
right where the sons of God come to
represent themselves um in the courts of
heaven and Satan actually comes as a
representative from Earth um and so then
that's you know part of that backstory
right and actually the whole book of job
I think is is a good um Exemplar of the
great controversy in some ways because
right there we see right Satan comes he
makes his charge against God or he makes
his charge right he says you know um oh
no actually
God I don't want to get this wrong but I
believe in opening chapter of job God
actually says have you seen my servant
job right that there's none like them
he's upright in the Nations he honors me
and then Satan says yeah but it's only
because you know you've blessed him and
you've prospered him right and so and
then we see right you know in job's life
right God says all right Satan I'll let
you to you know harm his family harm his
you know his goods and all that and yet
all through it job remains faithful
right and so I think that's another good
example right in scripture of this great
controversy theme so can I can I say
something real quick yeah a little bit
of a rebuttal so and and I'll get a
little bit of a nitpicky on here so
first of all um it's really important
when we're dialoguing with scripture
that we keep the context uh in the in
the Forefront so first of
all I would have quals with even stating
that Lucifer exists because and I'm I
don't want to get off on a rail too much
miles but here in verse 12 where it says
oh Day
star if you do any dialogue or any
interaction with the actual original
language Lucifer doesn't exist in
Scripture that is a transliteration of
the Latin ball gate that's correct
so and and again not that I I I think I
understand what people mean when they
say oh it's Lucifer um because of the
way it got its name through H and how
that's
translated but you would have to also
argue that this particular text is
actually talking about a Satan figure or
an adversary and really what's going on
here is it's about Babylon it's about
the king of Babylon I mean it's drawing
on some sort of a
conflict but I don't think Isaiah
actually is here you'd have to convince
me that this text is specifically
referring and I'm going to be very
specific to our topic to a
adversary that was in heaven prior to
Earth's creation you would have to
insert that into the
text uh in in order to get that under in
other words in order for Isaiah to be
stating that when he's proclaiming this
does that make sense yeah yeah I see
what you're saying so but in verse 12
right where it says how you are fallen
from Heaven oh Day star son of dawn
right I don't see how that could be just
the the king of
Babylon well so couple of things first
of all you have to look at the original
language what does it mean for something
to fall and is it fall from like is this
inferring so I'm asking questions here
is Isaiah speaking of a supernatural
being in heaven that has fallen from
outside of our atmosphere or some other
area onto Earth or is it some other is
he inferring some sort of other language
and I'm not trying to solve this problem
I'm just saying what I've what I've
realized is that the Adventist great
controversy
theme informs the way Adventists read
this
text so you'll come to this text and
you'll go see Lucifer fell from heaven
that's not what Isaiah is
saying that's what you're interpreting
it to say through your lens as and and I
say your as a 43 you know year avist
third generation AVST I was right there
with you okay it actually bothered me
when I found out that Lucifer wasn't
even in the Bible the first time I found
that
out um so that's my my big point would
be when we come to the text we have to
be careful that we're not we're not
using our filter and I think that's what
Herbert Douglas is saying in that
article is that Adventists filter things
through this because that's the way
everything is cohesive inside the
Adventist view if you don't use the
great controversy theme you can't get
what Adventists believe unless you have
it is that a fair assessment mil would
you agree with that or am I off
targeting yeah well and that's what I
was kind of getting at with you got to
do some deduction with the text and I
was actually just looking at the uh the
very opening page uh page 113 of the
fundamental beliefs book which gives the
exposition and our friend Joseph here
basically just reiterated what's stated
under the origin of the controversy
using the kings of Ty and Babylon as
figurative descriptions for Lucifer
scripture illuminates how this Cosmic
controversy began Lucifer son of the
morning the anointed covering cherub
resided in the presence of God Isaiah
14:12 and Ezekiel 28:14 scripture says
you were the Seal of perfection full of
wisdom and perfect in Beauty you were
perfect in your ways from the day you
were created till iniquity was found in
you Ezekiel 2812
through now Joseph we could even just
grant that this is talking about Satan
and there's still problems because all
this tells you is even if we ported
Satan into here I was Ascend to Heaven
above the Stars I will set my Throne on
high I will sit on the Mount of assembly
in the far reaches of the north I will
Ascend above the heights of the clouds I
will make myself like the most
high that all that is saying is that he
had a desire for something that doesn't
tell us that this was in response to
Jesus being exalted to be made equal
with the father or any of these other
details Christians believe what you you
know the the generals here some do some
don't some believe that Lucifer is
referring to Satan others like Mike said
um do not so those that do they're
recognizing this but they're not getting
out of this all these other details that
that are having to be attached to that
even with job and Revelation Revelation
12 is not talking about a war prior to
the creation of the Earth can we go to
re 12 sure and that much is obvious just
by the surrounding context it's it's
clearly um I mean human beings exist at
the point of the the war that's in Focus
here so it says now War arose in heaven
Michael and his angels fighting against
the dragon and the dragon and his angels
fought back but he was defeated and
there was no longer any place for them
in heaven and the Great Dragon was
thrown down that ancient serpent who is
called the devil and Satan the deceiver
of the whole world who was thrown down
to the Earth and his angels were thrown
down with him and I heard a loud voice
in heaven saying now the Salvation the
power and the kingdom for our God and
authority of his Christ have come for
the accuser of our brothers has been
thrown down who accuses them day and
night before God human beings already
exist at this point that this is not
referring to a War prior to the Earth
being created yet Ellen White and the
SDA Church try and apply this text in a
multifaceted way they try and apply it
to well there's going to be War later
that it could refer to but also it
refers to this pre-earth war that Ellen
White talked about well usually miles if
you go up usually what I have heard and
Joseph you can correct me if if I'm
misunderstanding this go all the way up
to verse uh three and four of chapter 12
because usually what I hear is that this
is in reference to Satan getting kicked
out of heaven prior to so his his tail
swept the third of the Angels correct
what I want to point out in this text is
if you read all of it instead of just
taking that verse out what does it say
in verse if you read verses four and
five what is that his tail swept down a
third of the stars of the heaven cast
them to the earth and the dragon stood
before the woman who was about to give
birth so that there so that when she
bore her child he might devour it she
gave birth a male child one who is to
rule so if you're going to keep it in
context when is when does the text say
this more than likely did happen what is
the context of the timing of the third
of the Angels getting kicked out the
Ascension some
that's the argument I I I the lane that
I I am in because this is clearly
talking about Jesus and Jesus being
caught up and and the Ascension and that
sort of thing and him going up and
presenting himself before the Father
which had
ramifications yeah it it certainly in my
opinion it certainly ties to the male
child who is to Rule now whether or not
a person takes that as the church or as
you know if if the woman is the church
or if the woman is Mary or if the woman
is like there's a lot of ways to parse
that out but it most certainly does not
have to do with prear
origin at least not in the context of
what Revelation is
discussing Joseph your thoughts well so
I I'll just uh turn around for the
question for you then so you're saying
um that when the devil the devil is cast
out right with a third of the Angels
that's not happening before the creation
of the world right like in other words
when when do you believe the sin problem
began well it depends uh in what context
you're referring now the the reality is
is the Bible is silent on a lot of this
information we don't have the creation
story of the angels we don't have a lot
of information so I try to not speak
Beyond where the Bible goes the avenus
system seems to be fine with well these
details don't contradict the Bible so
it's okay that we bring them along
because they help clarify that's
typically what I hear from Advent
scholarship Etc around Ellen White she
doesn't add anything to the Bible she
just adds details that aren't there that
help us better understand what is in the
Bible so I try to not speak on such
things um because the Bible doesn't
necessarily tell us it does tell us that
Satan was a murderer from the beginning
so clearly he had he he sinned clearly
and it tells us that sin entered the
world not through Satan through Adam
Romans 5 so that's as far as I
go yeah well I mean I and I I would
agree with what you're saying that when
when Adam sinned that's when the human
race that's when the human race rebelled
right like um the like Lucifer or sorry
Satan to use the language you guys more
comfortable with Satan right he wasn't
able to sin on behalf of mankind because
he wasn't you know human he was an angel
so um yeah I mean I guess like I said I
I I just saw this stream until I hopped
on I don't have exactly all the text I
would just say strongest arguments the
things that I was lean to obviously I do
think Isaiah 14 points to something but
then I think um when we go to job
particularly that I think that's a good
shows us kind of a behind the scenes
right of the controversy um and you know
if there's someone else who wanted to
hop on I appreciate you guys giving me
the time and by the way I got one just
one last question for you if you don't
mind for sure um when do you think job
when do you think the timeline of job
happened
oh I don't know exactly I I do I believe
the book was written by Moses if I'm not
mistaken well let me clarify sorry I
mean I mean like I mean like in time
when when do you think do you think the
story of Job happened prior to Earth's
creation no I I I do not believe that it
happened PRI prior to Earth creation so
if the war here in Revelation is
referring to a pre-earth war that took
place and Satan was banished then why in
the story of job is he back in
Heaven oh well I mean it could could we
actually go to job could we go to job
one like you want to go to job 18 um
yeah where it says well again I don't
want to say what it says let's read it
first no you're good and what once we
get into this I'd love to add something
that I find pretty interesting with with
job okay what verse would you like
Joseph okay so let me sorry um where it
says that he C where it says that he
came to present himself
therefore starting so verse okay can I
read can we read verse five and then
yeah go ahead can you see it on screen
you can read yeah so um we'll just five
star okay and in the days of the Feast
of under course job would send and
um maybe not I guess just verse six okay
uh now there was a day when the sons of
God came to present themselves before
the Lord and S uh Satan also came among
them then the Lord said to Satan from
where have you come Satan answered the
Lord and said from going to and fro on
the earth and from walking up and down
on it um and the Lord said to Satan okay
so there in verse seven right when Satan
answers I came from the earth so
obviously this is after he'd been cast
down after he'd been cast out because
he's on the earth um I guess that's what
point to do you know what Ellen White
had to say about Satan's banishment from
Heaven I don't know the exact wording no
okay well I won't hold you we don't have
to necessarily go into that I'm not
going to hold you accountable to that um
I was just curious uh if what what your
thoughts were on on all that so Mike you
said you had something you wanted to
chime in about well two things and I
don't want to derail us but with
relation to job first of all job is
probably the Book of Job is probably the
oldest book first of all correct um most
scholars believe that it's probably
written prior to um
Genesis not that again has too much
precedence to what we're talking about
but it is a very very old book and um
the other thing is is if you understand
the original language and I'm not a
linguistic U scholar okay but if you
look at the if you can go to the Hebrew
for
Satan real quick okay you want to go to
the inner linear just yeah for for verse
six where it says Satan and it'll be the
same for all satans I'm saying that
because that's the way the Hebrew word
um is used but Satan it's very it's very
important to
understand that in Hebrew it's different
than okay and I'm I'm trying to
understand in the way you have it set up
yeah see how it says H saton yep okay
the ha is is an article in yep it's
right there in Hebrew yep but it doesn't
get translated into the English text why
because if you
did in English it would say the
Satan okay it wouldn't have a capital
because Capital this is not a proper
noun in in the Hebrew grammar this is a
common noun and it should be translated
more like an adversary yep if you were
to properly translate the phrase It's an
adversary it's not the adversary it's a
adversary or an
adversary so I would actually have
contention linguistically personally to
attach I actually have a problem with
attaching a capital S even though I
understand why the translators do
it it translates too much to us as
English speaking Christian readers
because it makes the statement that this
is one specific specific individual and
it's the one that carries the Pitchfork
it's the devil okay y linguistically it
isn't necessarily in fact I give you a
couple of academic articles and books
that believe that this is more than
likely someone that's in the courts of
Heaven that are in favor they're not
necessarily
evil but they are called an
accuser because they're
accusing job and God is saying no he's
good
it's not necessarily someone who's evil
it's someone who's a who's making an
accusation so just a couple of points on
that that like and again to to mil's
point I always want to make sure that
what I do believe or what I can say I
believe is 100% backed by scripture not
just filled in by some other extra
biblical
stuff good stuff man oh Joseph go ahead
yeah I was just gonna say first all
appreciate you guys letting me come on
by the way I mean this all in a spirit
of Charity um and like I said keep
studying the Bible and um I got list um
well I'll just let you go maybe we'll
maybe we'll talk again someday cool
sounds good man anytime thanks for
stopping by than okay appreciate it have
a good one God
bless all right well that was great
folks thank you Joseph for coming on I
always applaud um Adventists that are
willing to do so my mind was not changed
um I I really need to see more from
these texts personally than just sort of
conjecture or assertions because
obviously I'm aware of all of these
proof texts but you have to Trojan horse
in a bunch of these details and the
reason these details are necessary folks
is because those details inform the core
understanding of fundamental beliefs
like I mentioned why did Jesus come to
the Earth the Bible doesn't teach why
Jesus came to the Earth for this or it
doesn't teach the same thing about that
as the Great controversy themed claims
the Bible does not teach that Jesus
Christ came to Earth to silence Satan's
accusations to vindicate the law of God
to all these watching intelligences to
ultimately vindicate God's character so
that they can see okay Satan is a liar
God can be trusted he is who he says he
none of that is in the Bible yet these
details like I said are an extra section
of Redemptive history that they claim to
supposedly have access to and that pre-b
information influences the later
revelation of the
Bible I uh I want to know have you
ever I'm trying to find in the article
where he specifically says it you know
where where Herbert Douglas says that it
was given yeah okay how how was it given
like does he do know clarify was is it
given by Ellen White is it given by it
it it has to be it has to there there's
no other place where is this because
it's it's essentially Revelation it's
revelatory what other person who do they
point to for any sort of divine
revelation it's coming from God so it
has to be of divine origin and it wasn't
discovered it was given to them so this
so This see this is my problem because
when you talk to an ainst you're gonna
you're G to hear them say oh no you
don't need Ellen White you can get it
all from scripture that's the common
rebuttal but then here you you see
someone who's being honest from an
academic standpoint and they no it was
it was given to us well
where right right in in Ellen White's
writings it's all this extra Revelation
that she supposedly gives them because
all these topics that he mentions she
informs all those even the the the topic
of herself what is her role she had a
lot to say about her own role so all the
doctrines that he mentions when he talks
about there at the beginning for Seventh
Adventist the great controversy theme is
the core concept that brings coherence
to all biblical subjects
well he then goes on to explain some of
those the great controversy theme helps
us to work our way through centuries of
theological confusion over the meaning
of such realities as
justification sanctification atonement
obedience and works without the great
controversy theme all would remain
divided over subjects like the
importance of the Old Testament
Sanctuary service and the New Testament
view of Christ as our high priest
mediator aka the investigative judgment
the meaning of faith and Grace the place
of obedience in relation to legalism why
Jesus came the first time why he came
the way he did and when he will return
so it's very clearly coming from Ellen
White and that's why you're you're stuck
in a conundrum you can't do the like I
tried to do it for a long time the
Adventist light thing U well ever heard
anyone argue that it comes from
somewhere else besides Ellen White no
because I can hardly ever get people to
even discuss this subject anytime I tend
to go down this road I was on the phone
uh I guess it's been a few weeks now
with uh David asterik and we got on to
talking about this stuff and he he he
tried to tell me he tried to say no no
no I don't even reference Ellen White I
just go with the Bible I said oh really
interesting I said well would you mind
showing me where the Bible says that
prior to Earth's creation Lucifer began
attacking the Ten Commandments becoming
Satan jealous of the exaltation of Jesus
well he sidestepped that he he moved off
of that he didn't want to talk about
that and so that's typically what tends
to happen in most of my experiences but
the people who I do talk to that really
do understand this typically Advent a
scholarship or or something in someone
in you know more on that side of the
spectrum no they recognize that this
stuff is coming from Ellen White and
they just try to use the defense that I
mentioned earlier they try the whole
well she doesn't contradict the Bible
none of this stuff contradicts the Bible
it just illuminates and adds details it
enhances the storyline to better help us
understand the Bible Mike this is the
same thing I hear from Mormons out on
the street when I do Mormon or Street
evangelism is that the Book of Mormon
does that exact thing it doesn't
contradict the Bible it just helps us
better understand the truth of the Bible
because it's another Testament of Jesus
Christ okay so so let me just let me
just play along for a second let let's
assume for the sake of argument that it
doesn't that that it just
illuminates why is it then that avist
have such a hard time when we test this
stuff to make sure it's
coherence well I think there's a variety
of answers you could give to that
because there's a spectrum you know not
all Adventist the gentleman who was just
on here bless that guy he was super
cordial super nice he was very honest um
you know so you have I think the average
Adventist is like that guy um just like
the average Christian in any Christian
Church you go into they're not a
theology nerd that they don't you know
they're just they're not so Miles well
you're just making a big deal about this
why is it such a big deal well here's
why it's a big deal because I'm speaking
on this platform organizationally I'm
speaking to the system I'm speaking to
the the system of Darkness I'm not
talking to all individual seventh day
Adventists in the sense that I'm saying
all seventh day Adventists are culpable
of some evil thing or or something like
that and it matters because millions of
people are being taken captive to this
and that's actually part of why it
matters Mike this platform has redpilled
I don't know how many people on this
reality that Holy Smokes wow I do have
this worldview WOW Christians don't
believe this stuff that is important
because they need to be woken up from it
they're T they're being taken captive by
this and they're able to to be pointed
to these proof texts like we just heard
and because they're not a theology nerd
or they're not really necessarily you
know really examining these things
really hard they're just kind of seeing
that well it does say that there was war
in heaven okay yeah it does say that
Lucifer became jealous oh okay and then
they hear Ellen White's quotes and it's
like oh yeah it just does it does
enhance what's there but folks any of us
could do that well sit down tonight and
write a bunch of pre-earth stuff that
none of it contradicts the Bible it's
all perfectly in harmony with the Bible
but they're details that aren't found in
the Bible like when like when she says
that Lucifer was pouting off in the
corner because he was mad and he was
plotting in his heart and his mind and
he had a he had that big forehead well
that's the that's at the beginning that
he had a he had a he had a uh what's the
word she says somebody his brow rid I
didn't even know that that broad
Angelic beings in heaven I didn't know
that they were human yeah oh you didn't
know they had
foreheads yeah and ears and and nose
yeah just news to me yeah but uh yeah
it's just like I don't think the average
person or even the average Seventh Day
Adventist like herb even not you know
recognizes at the beginning of this this
paper some may think of the great
controversy between Christ and Satan the
fifth book in the conflict of the ages
series but he says the great controversy
theme is more than a historical survey
of the battle between Christ and Satan
as traced through the events of secular
and Biblical history so because I don't
think the average SDA understands that
they're just being equipped with this
worldview and they're being
indoctrinated with it and it's
unsuspecting I know that's what it was
for me I vividly remember the day I
remember where I was I remember who I
was talking to when it dawned on me and
I had a light bulb moment where that
switch never turned off where I realized
wow the thing that's made me different
this whole time from Christians is I
have a different world view than them
they're not looking around at the world
and thinking all this stuff about oh
this is Satan doing this over here and
it's ultimately about hating the law and
he's trying to attack God's law now you
know and get humans to side with him and
all this this sort of stuff Christians
simply recognized that Satan is a foe
he's defeated he was defeated at the
cross and it doesn't go to all these
other added details about Satan's
satanic majesty and these other sort of
Blasphemous claims that he was next to
Christ in Authority that he had a brow
Ridge and that he was a the head of the
choir um you know these sorts of things
and and some of the things that I think
have the most important implication in
the avenus worldview that really do
matter because some of the like okay if
I get to heaven and I I'm wrong on like
the way this this devil person looks
like okay no big deal like okay fine but
when it comes to like the great
controversy theme teaches that the law
was intergral in not just human life but
Angelic Supernatural life that it was it
was precedent and in fact Angels live by
the same law that supposedly was given
at Mount Si for humans that same law is
what makes Heaven tick and the Sabbath
has a special Halo which means that all
of the Angels also celebrate Sabbath and
like this is this is what gets projected
on because what what is the Vindication
of God's character why does he even need
to be Vindicated like exactly it alls on
this pre-earth origin that the law and
all of this stuff is it's Downstream to
all of that yeah Barb thank you so much
for the five membership gifts
shout out to you thank you again so much
for your support all right Mike we have
our next 7th Day Adventist who wants to
step up to the plate Ricky you are up
Sir hello how are you I'm very well well
how are you I'm very well thank you for
asking miles I've been wanting to chat
with you for a while and I saw that you
had a question and answer so I thought
I'd hop on well it's not a question and
answer tonight my friend um I understand
you may have just gotten on the focus
tonight is the the open challenge of can
any Seven Day Adventist show us that the
Great controversy worldview is supported
strictly from the Bible so that is the
topic in Focus tonight and we would love
to hear from you um your support for
such yes miles uh when I was listening
earlier I noticed that she had a few qu
well a few points that you had brought
up and I took a few notes I noticed um
the caller before oh here we go yeah
perfectly uh yeah I noticed the caller
went ahead and attempted to try to
answer some of the backstory I guess
that was the original question about
well the backstory about Good and Evil
and is that biblical and the caller
answered with job and um aaya so I'd
love to move on to one of your next
points if you'd like sure and again
these are really just I only selected a
few of them because I was trying to
explain for the audience why these
details are important they can't just be
like well the they're kind of optional
because it is these specific details and
points that inform
why the Seventh Adventist Church claims
what they do for example about what the
cross was about why did Jesus go to the
cross and what was happening there that
is informed for the Adventist system
based on these pre-earth origin details
that Christians do not affirm so that is
why I brought these up as just some
examples of these sort of core details
from this storyline that because they
must be believed in order to properly
understand what the Bible is saying that
would then lead me to ask can you please
show me these then from the Bible yes of
course um so I guess I'll move on to
number two Lucifer became jealous of the
exaltation and began attacking the Ten
Commandments and accusing God of not
being fair okay well the first verse
that comes to mind about that would be
Ezekiel
28:15 okay so we just read that earlier
from the just a second you said Ezekiel
28 yes because um yes of course because
we just we just read that earlier from
the uh the fundamental beliefs book oh
wonderful so I guess we're answering our
own questions no you're you're good so
let's bring this up here we can look at
this again would you mind bringing up
the King James version please
okay let's bring up the King
James are you a textus receptus only
guy no
comment okay I'll take that as a yes
it's a no
okay all
right um okay well the verse that I was
referring to was in relationship to how
from the day that essentially
paraphrasing how from the day that well
let's read it since it's up what what
verse would you like to read uh Ezekiel
28:15 okay go ahead and read
it let's see uh thou was perfect in thy
ways from the day that thou was created
till iniquity was found in thee okay and
you think that this supports that prior
to the Earth's creation Lucifer became
jealous of the exaltation of Jesus to be
equal with God the father and then began
attacking the Ten Commandments and
saying that God is a liar and the law
can't be because if ye if ye violate the
least of The Commandments ye violate
them all and before the Ten Commandments
the Commandment was iniquity
where does any of that say Jesus was
exalted prior to Earth's creation
Lucifer became jealous of this and then
began attacking the Ten
Commandments I think it's
self-explanatory that iniquity was the
command iniquity was the Commandment
that was broken and we've already we've
already read that the evil one was cast
down from heaven obviously because of
sin and this was the iniquity and so the
this answers question too from the
perspective that obviously sin was found
in the heart of the evil one and that's
why and that's what separated him and
cast him down from Heaven to Earth now
as far as the other uh particular points
we're going to have to go on those
individually if you'd like can I ask a
clarifying question Ricky of course
Michael um verse 15 who who is in the
context of this chapter in Ezekiel who
is
the individual being referred to here
thou was perfect who who who is the thou
I I know that earlier you were
discussing this person I don't prefer to
like harp on the evil one it says there
in 14 the anointed cherub and you've
discussed already whom that is well no
hold on who so can we go up to verse 11
I always I really get uncomfortable
reading one verse
and I know that we're not doing a big
like study or anything but moreover the
word of the Lord yahawah came unto me
saying what's the problem with 11 keep
keep going saying
what a son of man take up a lamentation
upon the king of Tyrus and say unto him
thus sayith the Lord God thou seest up
the sum of full wisdom and perfect in
Beauty so who's the king of Tyrus
he is the Royal of Tyrus what's the
question Mike well if you keep moving
through the text everything that's
happening in 13 14 15 this is a
lamentation against the king of Tyrus
and do you believe that the king of
Tyrus was an
Eden well I believe that it is a it is a
Ezekiel is
using something common again this is
getting into my understanding of what
ezekiel's talking about okay was he also
uh encrusted with barrel and Onyx and
Jasper and Sapphire and emerald and
found perfect in his days so so most
academic Scholars when they understand
this when they interpret this okay and
I'm talking about interpretation for a
second okay because we're getting into
like how a person reads the text I
understand that the Adventist view would
read this as the
devil I don't think that's
fair I think that Ezekiel is using a
common understanding everyone knew
during that day and age about the the
thing back in the garden of Neen like
everyone knew that but this is a
lamentation against a physical King and
he's using an analogy of what happened
back in the Garden of Eden if you study
the whole the whole text as a lament
against the king of
Tyre
so yes there was a cherub back in the
Garden of Eden I don't disagree with
that like we all know that we know we
all kind of most the Cherub was covering
the
ark what you I guess we can move on
okay well hold up hold up here hold up
here even I'm gonna say the same thing
we said to Joseph even if we grant that
this is talking about Satan we're doing
a lot even if we Grant this is about
Satan can we talk about anything other
than Satan can we talk about our savior
perhaps I think number two is already
Rick Ricky Ricky you Ricky you are the
one that said you wanted to talk about
two which has to do with Satan
Adventists are the ones that are
obsessed in love
Satan first of all I don't think
that's hold on Ricky Ricky Ricky Ricky
Ricky
okay if you're going to talk over and
try and run the show we will move on you
need to calm down and just relax we're
just having a conversation my friend
this I understand you know you I watched
a lot of my videos and I those are my
stump speeches but we're having a
one-on-one conversation here I I don't
get that way when I'm just having like a
one-on-one conversation just chill bro
just chill we're we're just we're just
talking we're just talking okay I'm
gonna unmute you but let me finish
because I let you finish and then Mike
went I'm saying even if we grant that
this is talking about Satan because
that's what you want to pull in there
there's nothing in here Ricky about
Lucifer beginning to attack the Ten
Commandments out of jealousy of Jesus
being exalted jealousy that was hold on
hold on okay that was not that was not
demonstrated those details are being
ported into this text they're not being
derived from the text that is classic
isog Jesus so you haven't demonstrated
that well all I have to do is
demonstrate iniquity and I demonstrate
jealousy because no no no you don't if
ye transgress the least of the commands
then ye transgress them all so that
doesn't have anything to do with Jesus
being exalted Ricky that doesn't have
anything to do with Satan attacking the
ten commands are you suggesting that
Jesus is not
exalted Ricky the storyline claims that
prior to Christ's Incarnation we're not
talking about as a man yes of course as
a man Christ ascended that's as a man
that's not as Yahweh so do you affirm
the hypothetic Union which the SDA
Church claims to affirm that Christ is
100% man 100% God simultaneously and
those two Natures exist in the one
person and his Unity of divine and human
Natures come at the point of that single
person do you agree with that sorry I
was a little bit confused by that word
you
said okay sorry I'll say it again the
Adventist Church claims to uphold the
hypostatic union which is the one that
started with a with a Y and a what did
you say
th this this apparently I think Ricky
you're you're probably on a a thing
about Yahweh and you don't want that to
be said I'm sorry I you were talking to
Okay Lord Lord Jesus Christ is the
almighty Jesus Christ is the almighty do
you affirm the hypothetic union um I'm
sorry I'm not sure I understood that
word that you said with the J could you
say that again whom are you referring
okay so you're not a serious individual
Ricky Ser individual
if you don't want to be a serious
individual
because okay Ricky if you're going to
play games and try and waste time and
troll we're going to move along you know
what I'm getting at you're now trying to
obfuscate away from the fact that the
Bible does not teach that prior to
Christ's
incarnation in heaven he was exalted to
be made equal with God the father that
Authority devolved
onto him from the
father that is what is in focus in point
two on this chart don't point to verses
in the Bible that talk about Jesus post
Incarnation as a man being exalted as
the new Adam the second Adam the one who
fulfilled what the first Adam failed to
do and inherits the promises that Adam
would have fulfilled had he kept
Covenant okay so we're going to try this
one more time yes of course if you play
these games again
we're just going to move along because
we're trying to have a serious dialogue
I'm being friendly with you we want to
listen we want to have a genuine serious
edifying discussion here so wonderful be
be mature okay yes miles I am not
trolling you I am in fact very serious
about my savior and the answer is quite
clear from the text from which I know
and that is relating to the fact
that our
savior was before the foundation of the
world let me ask you was our savior
still the son of the almighty from
before the foundation of the
world um well it depends what you mean
by those words I don't I'm gon I'm
trying to be charitable I don't agree
that you and I believe in the same the
same God if you affirm the Adventist god
um so I would even ask that that's a bit
frustrating because isn't it blasphemy
to speak on to speak on someone without
cause or like have anger or uh what
evidence did I give to you which causes
you to believe what did I say which
causes you to believe that I do not
believe in the almighty God and his
son well I said if for one but two the
fact that you are an Adventist that's
obviously what I'm operating off of so
me if I was an Adventist yeah Ricky well
only Adventists are supposed to join
tonight that's in the link did you not
listen did you
in fact I read it however I attend the
Seventh Day Advent message Kissa and as
I acknowledge they call themselves
corporately The Seventh Day Adventist
Church okay well that's not our fault
Ricky that's your fault so why fa miles
what's my fault miles so
okay goodbye
Ricky Mercy not even a Seventh Day
Adventist okay great
we have somebody else who wants to come
up though Mike so let's move on can we
clarify before they start can we clarify
that they actually are seventh day
athenus I don't even know what he said
he said some sectarian messenger of
something something something it's like
why side note Miles this doesn't
surprise me and I'm not GNA release
names when I say this but I have a
friend that is a pastor I'll just say it
that way that's an Adventist Pastor that
behaves as a Messianic Jew
yeah just confusing well it's like I'm
not going to saddle the Seventh
Adventist Church with that guy I mean
I'm not going to saddle the the
corporate you know system and whatnot
with any individual SDA but like my
point is is like it's irrelevant what
you say then guy like what that's not
what this is for no we're talking about
seventh day adventism the the the
corporate organization not these
offshoot Splinter random whatever but
okay we have by the way aren isn't this
supposed to unify can I just say that
like didn't Herbert Douglas say that
like the great controvery theme is
supposed to like unify all like and yeah
we someone coming on that's like not
even well not just that but he freaked
out about me like why' you assume this
Ricky I tried to ask you about if you
affirm the hypothetic union to to learn
to to make sure before saying anything
and he was playing games so very clearly
was not a serious individual but let's
bring our third person on
here we don't know what your name is
because it's too full um and your camera
apparently doesn't work and your mic is
muted but whoever you are reveal
yourself who are you hello uh yes my
name is Ross hi Ross are you a Seventh
Day Adventist yes okay part of the
actual 7th Day Adventist Church not some
offshoot thing like the previous
guy yeah
a okay are you a baptized member in the
Seventh Adventist Church yes
okay wonderful okay thank you um yeah
the the floor is yours let's hear uh
whatever you'd like to present as the
proof that the great controversy theme
is strictly from the Bible okay I think
the the question from the last person
they they were trying to answer was
about uh was about Lucifer I guess or
something like that about U sort of the
connection between Lucifer and Jesus
prior to Jesus coming to Earth
that is correct he was trying to focus
on uh let me get it brought up here he
was trying to focus on point number two
of this chart which is the CLA became
jealous of the
exaltation and began attacking the Ten
Commandments Ross your mic is really
broken up and you're getting that really
robotic Jitter sound so we're not
actually hearing you right
now nope
um you may have some bad service that
may not be able
to yeah we're getting hard hard robotics
on your end do you have your camera
actually turned off or just something
covering it
okay um we're going to remove you from
the studio and we are going to Ross you
are free to I'm gonna I'm going to
remove you and you are free to join back
in if you would like but we're not able
to get anything that he's saying there
that's really unfortunate because I was
really looking forward to whatever he
was about to say so Ross please come
back if you uh if you can sometimes I
know that people resetting their it
sound like he was on a mobile device
sometimes closing out and coming back in
resets all that stuff
so yeah so so Miles I want to like to to
the last conversation and I think it
pointed out while it was a little bit
odd I think it does point out that one
thing I want to be clear on is this
world viiew and this is kind of what
we're hitting on the world viiew is a a
lens that an individual
sees life or interprets the text or
seees
your religious experience or your
however you want to phrase it it's the
lens through which you see all things
that's what a world viw is just like the
ancient near
Eastern worldview they had a perspective
in the Old Testament of how they
interacted how they saw how God
interacted with them that whole
view so the the great controversy theme
is that for Adventists and so a lot of
times what I'm giving push back is isn't
because and I just want to I want to
clarify this if my dad is watching I'm
just going to say
this because every time I respond it's
oh you just think you're right oh you
just want to disagree oh you you just
think you know everything it's that kind
of a kind of a response and my ask is
does the text say that or is that your
interpretation of what the text is
saying through your worldview
yeah because that's the key that's the
key question and it it almost kind of
reminds me of just even like the
Reformation it's like the the core Crux
of the Reformation we get caught up in
all these sort of like solos scriptura
and the Solas and ecclesiology and yeah
but all of that stuff is Downstream the
the real rub of the Reformation was a
hermeneutically driven struggle that's
what it was over it was over
hermeneutics which is why I'm constantly
bringing up the uh historical
grammatical method of Bible
interpretation that Ted Wilson tells us
is the only approved hermeneutic in the
SDA church yet they just can't seem to
utilize it for some reason how do we use
that method to to approach the great
controversy thing yeah no no kidding
right it's like comments like this I
called out miles that he brings a
Catholic to share their Doctrine and he
said he doesn't it's like oh man talk
about the the rewriting if this is the
individual that I'm I'm recalling again
we get lots of uh comments and sometimes
Adventists make the same sorts of claims
so maybe this wasn't this individual but
this is a funny Twist on how I've never
I've never claimed that no Catholic has
come on here and espoused any sort of
Catholic Doctrine because guess what
some things that Catholics believe isn't
entirely unique to Catholics my guess is
this is uh having Steven Boyce on here
when he talked about Mary being in focus
in the Book of Revelation Well Steph
Boyce is an Anglican Sam shimone has
also said the same thing on this
platform believe it or not that belief
is not only Roman Catholic but uh
instead of actually coming on here this
individual is just commenting this sort
of stuff in the chat which is why it's
like spare me all your silly rhetoric
come on here and um defend what's in
Focus tonight and don't try and do the
whole like uh poisoning of the well or
the ad homm or or these sorts of things
which really solve nothing because
believe it or not folks I bring people
on here Mike you were on here to discuss
with an Adventist when I was moderating
and guess what folks Mike and I believe
some stuff differently regarding the
law oh man and guess what I'm going to
Spill the Beans next week there's going
to be Adventist and a Roman Catholic on
the platform to
debate the nature of death and if death
is asleep uh oh I bring people on here
Mike who believe things differently than
I do shocker yeah believe it or not
folks I don't just live in an echo
chamber we shouldn't just live in an
echo chamber just because it's like
people on on X how they'll put in their
uh their bio or whatever retweets do not
equal like my own beliefs or like you
know retweets do not Auto automatically
mean that just affirm everything this
person says by virtue of what have you
SD have gotten on this really B out of
shape kick here with Sam shimone coming
on the platform periodically and it's
just so funny it's like Sam is my friend
Sam disdains Protestant theology he
absolutely hates reformed theology yet
he knows I'm reformed that this silly
notion that like I'm this like covert
Roman Catholic and I just won't tell
people it's like oh yeah I'm one of
those I'm one of those Presbyterian
Jesuits so but what you're saying
actually it's funny because it actually
stems from the great controversy theme
yeah because that theme actually teaches
Adventists to look at every single other
denomination especially the Catholic
denomination yeah okay as other than as
evil as whatever so it doesn't surprise
me that that whatever that guy that you
showed on here that comment it doesn't
surprise me that that Patricio Mo
whoever that is um got PTSD with with
Catholic response well another perfect
example here and we've tal me and you
have talked about this before Mike like
I said the fact that Protestants here
want Sam to help miles is funny oh
believe it or not um yeah Roman
Catholics actually you can learn
something from them that's the problem I
have with adventism Mike like one of the
major problems I have with adventism is
this hyper averse fear to like you can
learn something from somebody who
doesn't look identical to you do even
Roman Catholics uh yeah I've learned a
lot from a ton of Roman Catholics I I've
read John dun scotus uh Thomas aquinus
the sort of medieval Scholastics um all
the way back to even early patristics I
don't agree with everybody that I read
but I also recognize that people I
disagree with on even some pretty big
matters they can still teach you things
in other areas and when you shut
yourself off from that sort of thing um
you really limit yourself in terms of
how much you can actually learn and eat
the meat spit out the bones well if if
you want to way to never know what your
blind spots are and your theology just
surround yourself people that think just
like you yep well our friend is back
here so let's see if it works this time
Ross you are
back all right that better work it is
better it is better yes we can hear you
now so is yours all right so I think
we're looking at about uh about Jesus
having a controversy with well not Jesus
with Satan having a
with Jesus let's see um being jealous of
his exaltation okay yeah that prior to
Earth's
creation Lucifer became jealous of the
exaltation of Jesus becoming Satan the
adversary who began attacking the Ten
Commandments and accusing God of not
being
fair
okay um let's see you can focus on
something else if you want that's just
what the previous person was was
focusing on but we'd love to hear any
any biblical proof for any of the great
controversy theme okay let's see I'll
try to I'll start with I guess maybe
John one you know it just says in the
beginning here I'll bring I'll bring it
up okay do you have any translation you
prefer uh the King James okay so you
want to do John 1 one yeah okay yeah
John chapter one get that yeah cool
let's get that brought up here
okay um so it says in the beginning was
the word and the Word was with God so
where talking about the word is talking
about Jesus but at the same time A lot
of times the Bible you know it's kind of
repeating and large and it uses you know
different kinds of symbols at times so
Jesus is he was his character is
reflection of the word and the word is
his character meaning like everything we
have in scripture telling us you know
what God is like you know and and you
know narrowing down his character The
Ten Commandments that's all encompassing
who God is as a as an entity you know
like the relationship that we're
supposed to have with God where we're
supposed to refence God basically in the
first four in the first tablet with the
first four Commandments and then the
second tablet is how we're supposed to
deal with people that's all reflection
of God because his character is selfless
everything God does
he doesn't think about himself he thinks
about others and how it's going to
affect them unlike us where you know
unfortunately human beings we're flawed
we're messed up we know that but anyway
uh it's saying in the beginning was the
word let me pause right there the word
is Jesus the word is also the word of
God it's one and the same and the and
the Word was with God and the Word was
God so it's kind of telling us right
there that Jesus and the father were
always together you know they're
separate beings they're on the same page
they like a family that's kind of where
people get confused I know I see atheist
sometimes say well you know God saved
himself to crucify himself and it's just
nonsense it's you know and it also if we
go I'm kind of jumping around but in
general us make God in our image and you
have the notion of Elohim which is
plural for God even though um you know
God is basically it's a little confusing
I know to to us human beings we probably
understand it more in eternity but God
is like a a collective it calls it the
godhead I know in the in the old in the
new test and that just means they're
working together they each kind of seem
to have different jobs they do and it
also you know in Jesus was talking to
the disciples and they told him you know
show us the father um Jesus at that
point was saying you know have I not
been with you so long that you don't
know you know that I and the father are
one you know that you have seen the
father because they're the same in
character though they have different
jobs that they do Jesus is the high
priest he's our intercessor basically um
and so anyway let me go back to John one
and kind of I'm going off on the r know
in the beginning was the word and the
Word was of God and the Word was God so
it's let this know Jesus and the word of
God are one that's also including those
Commandments because you know God's law
is also who he is as well as his Justice
and his Mercy it's all wrapped up in the
one there's not one part of that that's
strong the other it's all equal with
God and then it says the same was in the
beginning uh with God you know so let
know Jesus With God all things were made
by him just letting us know that Jesus
was the one that created everything God
God took a part of this the Holy Spirit
as well but Jesus was the one sort of
tasked to do this I guess they were all
there like I think of it kind of like as
a
workshop because I have a background of
sort of you know being artist and making
things I think of it like hey they it
was a workshop and they all and you know
hey you know you should do this Jesus
and do that you know they probably
talked about it beforehand but Jesus was
the one putting everything together with
his word
and without him was not
anything him was life and the life was
the light of men and the light shineth
in darkness and the Darkness
comprehended it not and it's letting you
know here uh what do it say here next uh
there was a man sent from God there's
going into John the uh Baptist and the
same came as it went for witness to Bear
witness to the light Jesus being the
light but you also have references if we
go back toh what was it there this is
where it gets a little confusing to
Isaiah 14 let's jump over there I
think yeah we were just there earlier
okay what verse uh I said starting at
the beginning okay let's see uh let's
read it says for the Lord will have
mercy on Jacob and will yet choose
Israel and yet and set them in their own
land okay okay and the people shall take
them and bring them like jump down I
guess hard
bondage th shall take the Lord have
broken
supp we got to go back down further I
think where you were talking about the
king of tire yep that's where we were
earlier where was that at
here okay let's go back up a little
bit seear okay well let's see I guess 12
there
really yeah it's kind
of I'm not totally familiar with is I
should be more familiar with it but uh
where it has 12
here What's happen what happens I guess
you could say with
the also make a reference to something
else but let me go into this here I
don't want I want stick to the facts I
come to see you
got uh 12 it says how art thou fallen
from Heaven oh
Lucifer that is a direct reference to
Satan the devil all those names some
people say well there some people
confused they think that there's the
same that's the same person you know you
want to call them be all they as that in
the Bible all the same son of the
morning okay
so he was like a lesser light than Jesus
but he was a he was like considered
angel light Lucifer means light he was a
lightbearer okay how art thou cut down
to the ground which did US weaken the
Nations okay which which nations talking
about obviously Earth uh for thou H has
said in thine heart I will Ascend into
heaven I will exalt my throne above the
stars of God so
basically above all the other angels and
followers of
God I will sit upon the Mount of the
congregation in the sze of the north
okay where is that that's what God
says okay that's what he's saying there
he's saying that Lucifer wants to sit
where God sits or who else sits where
God sits the Father and Jesus they share
the throne so right there it's telling
you that he must be there's a conflict
there he's jealous of them he hates them
whatever because he loves himself more
all this is the wording of somebody if
you were if you if you were say this is
Lucifer saying this instead of Isaiah
writing this and it's basically saying
he's saying you know uh how are there
Fallen oh Lucifer Sunday morning for
thou has said in thine heart this is
what Lucifer is saying in his heart he's
saying I Lucifer will Ascend into heaven
and I Lucifer will exalt my throne above
the stars of God I'm going to be God and
I will sit up on the Mount of the
congregation I'm going to sit where God
sits God you move out of the way
Lucifer's in town I'm going to sit here
and the sides of the north I will Ascend
above the heights of the clouds clouds
is a reference to
Angels I will be like the most high he's
saying I'm gonna be God here yet Thou
shalt be brought down to Hell so he's
let you know okay Lucifer this is what
you think is going to happen but this is
what is actually going to happen you're
going to be destroyed
to the sides of the pit which is the
grave which is death is what he's saying
which is what's going to happen and to
Lucifer in the end if we jump to
Revelation you can read how Lucifer is
going to be destroyed um they that set
the see thee shall narly look upon thee
and consider thee saying is this the man
that made the Earth to tremble that did
Shake
kingdoms that made the world as a
Wilderness and destroyed the cities
thereof that open not the house of his
prisoners you know open not the grave
you know Jesus was the only one that
escaped the grave and he took a few
captains with him he when he did Escape
praise the Lord all the kings of the
Nations each all of them lie in glory
everyone in his own house but thou are
cast out of the Grave like an abominal
branch and as the REM rment of those
that are slain let's see
uh oops I lost my
page let's go
back if I can
find Ross I'm gonna give you about 30
more seconds to to kind of wrap it up
because there's a lot that's being said
that we that we want to definitely
address well I'll kind of wrap it up
basically you can see there that
obviously it's talking about Lucifer and
his nature his selfishness how he wanted
to be raised above God how you want to
sit where God is and if you're sitting
where God is you're also sitting where
Jesus is they share the throne as far as
you know everything that the father has
he has given to Jesus so it's letting
you know right there that there is a
conflict between Christ and Satan that
Lucifer hates Jesus and what did he do
when he when Jesus came down here he put
Jesus on the cross through using the
Roman armies to do it and you know using
the hierarchy and the Jewish Community
the the church Elders basically to
falsely accuse Jesus so he could be
destroyed
and you know that's That's what Satan
does he's a destroyer he's a
liar okay there's a couple things I'm
going to chime in here on and then I
know Mike is going to want to talk about
Isaiah here so couple things Ross I
appreciate your candidness I appreciate
your demeanor you're you seem like a
very nice guy um and so don't take
offense to any of the stuff that I'm
saying I'm just kind of responding here
to some of the stuff you said so let's
actually look back at what the point is
that's in contention
yeah the claim is made that prior to the
creation of the
earth Lucifer became jealous of the
exaltation of Jesus to be made equal
with God the
father he led to this led to him
becoming Satan God's adversary who began
attacking the Ten Commandments and
accusing God of not being fair we didn't
see any of that in what we read we
didn't see any of that in John 1:1 so
for example John 1 the word that is used
there for word is logos you know what
logos
means some people will say some people
will say logos but it's it's
logos so it's not necessarily referring
to the Bible there um I do understand
that the word word can be referring to
the word of God but there specifically
it's referring to Christ the son and you
were correct in that but nothing in John
one for example tells us that Lucifer
became jealous prior to the creation of
the Earth because Jesus was exalted to
be made equal with God the Father you
also said that God the father Jesus and
the Holy Spirit are separate beings um I
would advise you against using that
language if you're claiming to be a
trinitarian I know the SDA church or
within adventism at least it it's
because Ellen White ultimately did um
when you say that what you're actually
saying is they're there are three
different gods the word being denotes
state or mode of existence so the the
IAL God is not three distinct beings the
the biblical God is one single being who
exists in three
persons so father son and spirit are the
one God and this kind of gets to the
core of the problem prior to Earth's
creation Jesus was never exalted to be
made equal with God the father because
Jesus ontologically already is equal
with God the Father there is no
exaltation to take place furthermore the
doctrine of inseparable operations while
that phrasing is not found in the Bible
it is just the summation phrase for what
we do see in the Bible and according to
the Bible the father son and the spirit
do nothing separate of from one another
so for example if we talk about the
resurrection I can show you in scripture
where it says the father resurrected
Jesus Jesus resurrected himself and the
Holy Spirit resurrected Jesus I can show
you with creation that the father
created the son created and the Holy
Spirit created Etc they're not distinct
or separate beings but I think that kind
of gives us some insight into how a
person can can kind of believe some of
these things that are being put forth
and not see necessarily the problems but
at its core nothing we read in Isaiah
specifically says that Lucifer became
jealous of Jesus being exalted to be
made equal with God the father and then
began attacking the Ten Commandments
leading to a war in heaven we just got
General details that Lucifer wanted to
exalt himself now Mike is going to
disagree or as he as he was saying
previously and I'm tring to kind of stay
neutral out of I'm just granting for the
sake of the discussion that sure Satan
can be in Focus but we didn't get any of
those details those details are having
to be brought to the text to help
interpret now there's a couple things
that I want to talk about regarding you
said that the father and the son are on
the throne Ross do you believe the holy
spirit is on the
throne um it doesn't say that the Holy
Spirit on the throne so I can't I can't
comment on that okay do you have your
Bible
uh yes I did okay can you go to
revelation 22 for
me and we're going to just do a little
bit of a walkthrough here I know it's
kind of off the path here of the the
great controversy theme but I I want you
to to see this because you like I said
you sound like a nice guy you sound like
a guy that really does want to believe
the truth that wants to believe the
Bible Etc can you read uh I'm gonna
bring it up on screen here can you read
for us revelation 22
1-3 okay Revelation chapter 2 13 yes
yep okay and he showed me a pure River
of Life clear as Crystal proceeding out
of the Throne of God and of the
Lamb yeah so you have the Throne of God
and the lamb there on the throne in the
midst of the street of it and on the
other side of the river was there the
Tree of Life which beare 12 manner of
fruits and yielded her fruit every month
and the leaves of the tree were for the
healing of Nations and there shall be no
more curse but the Throne of God and of
the Lamb shall be in it and his servants
Shall Serve him okay so who do you see
here that's on the throne I see the
father and I see Jesus okay and what
does it tell you in verse one proceeds
from the
throne uh proceeding out of the Throne
of God and the lamb is the uh the River
of Life okay so remember that River of
Life okay yep okay now if you can go to
John well actually let's stay let's
let's do both of of Revelation um so you
got that so it's the river right that's
that's
flowing yes and just again I know you've
already said this but I just want to see
in the the mouth of multiple Witnesses
obviously Revelation 3:21
to him that overcometh will I grant to
sit with me in my throne even as I
overcame and am set down with my father
in his throne who's talking
here okay let me see here you're on
three and on verse 20 yeah Revelation
3:21 okay uh behold I stand at the door
and knock If any man hear my voice and
open the door I will come in to him and
will s with him and he with me to him
that over cometh will I grant to sit
with me in my throne even as I also
overcame and am set down with the father
in his throne he'd have an ear uh let
him hear what the spirit saith onto the
churches so who's on the throne with the
father uh Jesus okay cool I just like I
said I want to see multiple amounts of
witnesses okay so remember what
revelation 22 told us what proceedes
from the throne
uh the River of Life yep all right now
let's go to John 7
okay can you read John 7 38-39 for me
okay okay he that believeth in me as the
scripture have said out of his belly
shall flow rivers of Living
Water but this spake he of the spirit
which they that believe on him should
receive for the Holy Ghost was not yet
given because that Jesus was not yet
glorified whoa whoa whoa
Ross what did what did he what did we
just what did we just read about the the
the River of
Life um that it flows from God there and
who and who does Jesus tell us uh who's
going to flow out of his belly
uh the
spirit go here did you catch that
Ross it's because we're reading the King
James that you may have missed it so let
me move over the nesb and the ESV get
this really really well well while
you're pulling that up I think it's also
important to note that this is
John yes Revelation was written by who
John correct now I know the headings are
not inspired Ross but notice the heading
River of Living Water I'm going to read
it here in the ESV on the last day of
the feast the great day Jesus stood up
and cried out if anyone thirst let him
come to me and drink whoever believes in
me as scripture has said out of his
heart will flow rivers of Living Water
now this he said about the
spirit whom those who believed in him
were to receive for as yet the spirit
had not been given because Jesus was not
yet glorified Ross revelation 22 doesn't
just have the father and the son on the
spir on the throne did you catch this
okay then the angel showed me the river
of Water of Life bright as Crystal
flowing from the Throne of God and of
the
Lamb okay this is the holy spirit
proceeding from the
throne this isn't whether there's a
literal River or not I know the
Adventist system tends to want to read
everything you know if it's if it sounds
like it's literal we should take it
literal and I get that you know to to
some degree but this is talking about
the spirit proceeding from the father
and the son which is why at least in the
west the western church the Eastern
Church disagrees with this there's a
huge conflict there was a Schism over
this it was that big of a deal but
nevertheless the western church was
correct sorry to my Eastern Orthodox
friends and listeners and Oriental
Orthodox and Assyrian Church of the East
but the West got this correctly the it
says in the ncing Creed that the spirit
proceeds from the father and the son and
this is why because the spirit is also
on the throne here so um I I just wanted
to to point that out for you um because
I was curious when you said that the the
father and the son were on the throne
Ellen White when she talked about this
she never even mentioned anything
regarding the spirit in creation um at
least early on that that came later
on her Theology of the Holy Spirit
started to develop later on in her life
so early on in a lot of the groundwork
of the stuff she she wasn't really
mentioned so I just wanted to point that
out but then the the last thing I I do
want to point out um because I do think
it's really important in the mic I'm G
to let you go um you said that Satan put
Jesus on the cross was that
correct yes he helped him yeah yeah so
can you go to Acts chapter
4 let's
see okay okay just one second I'm trying
to get it brought up
here uh just a second sorry Ross I'm
having an you here
again it's because of your comment about
those Eastern people that you
yeah Ross I'm sorry I told you the wrong
chapter that's why I'm a goofball go to
Acts chapter two I'm sorrys two again
got to got to the wrong section of
Peter's sermon there and I crossed some
wires
okay sorry now I'm trying to get this
brought up after knocking stuff down
here okay so we are gonna go
down okay so Peter is in the middle of
his let me get this brought over to here
Peter is in the middle of his sermon on
Pentecost
okay and can you read for me 22 through
okay uh ye men of Israel he these words
Jesus of Nazareth a man approved of God
among you by Miracles and wonders and
signs which God did by him in the midst
of you as ye yourselves also know 23 him
being delivered by the determined
counsel and for knowledge of God ye have
taken and by Wicked hands have crucified
and slain 24 whom God have raised up
having Loos the Pains of death because
it was not possible that he should be
Holden of it all right so what does it
tell you here specifically in verse
three about the
crucifixion it's telling you that the
council's brought up you know Jesus to
be
crucified yeah and it well it says this
Jesus delivered up so Peter is telling
he's he's preaching to a Jewish audience
of of people here the people that
crucified Christ and he says men of
Israel hear these words Jesus of
Nazareth so they would have all been
familiar who this individual was they
had just recently killed him you know a
man attested to you by God with Mighty
works and wonders and signs that God did
through him in your midst as you
yourselves know this Jesus delivered up
according to the definite plan and forn
knowledge of God you crucified and
killed by the hands of Lawless men now
we have to look to a parallel that
foretold of this taking place so can you
flip to Isaiah
53 all right let's go
there and I think while you're going
there I think your your point there
miles is that verse 23 delivered up
according to the definite plan and forn
knowledge of God that is correct and
we're going to see something in in in
regards to that plan because there's
prophetic significance to that okay
what's Isaiah what the Isaiah yep Isaiah
53 okay and we're going to
start let me get this brought over
here uh share this tab step okay so I'm
going to read here from verse six for a
little bit okay
okay well hold up let's go back to to
four so it's talking about it's four
Talent you agree that this is a a
Messianic song or prophecy that it's for
telling about
Christ that's fine if you don't want to
say yes yet familiar with it right okay
so he said so Isaiah says let me just
start at the beginning then if you're to
to make sure we get everything caught up
he says who has believed what he has
heard from us and to whom has the arm of
the Lord been revealed for he grew up
before him like a young plant and like a
root out of dry ground he had no form or
Majesty that we should look at him and
no beauty that we should desire him he
was despised and rejected by Men A Man
of Sorrows and acquainted with
grief and as one from whom men hid their
faces he was despised and we esteemed
him not yes surely he has borne our
griefs and carried our sorrows yet we
esteemed him stricken Smitten by
God H and
Afflicted but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities upon him was the chastisement
that brought us peace and with his
wounds we are
healed all like sheep have gone astray
we've turned everyone to his own way and
the lord has laid on him the iniquity of
us
all he was oppressed and he was
afflicted yet he opened not his mouth
like a lamb that was led to the
slaughter and like a sheep that before
it shears is silent so he opened not his
mouth by oppression and judgment he was
taken away and as for his generation who
considered that he was cut off out of
the land of the living stricken for the
transgression of my people and they made
his grave with the wicked and with a
rich man in his death although he had
done no violence and there was no deceit
in his
mouth yet it was the will of the Lord to
crush
him he has put him to grief when his
soul makes an offering for Guilt he
shall see his offering he shall prolong
his days the will of the Lord shall
prosper in his hand
so Ross do you agree that this is
foretelling about Jesus oh yes
definitely what were you told in verse
10 says yet it was his will it was the
will of the Lord to crush him he was put
uh he has put him to grief okay so two
things who crushed
Christ um it says the will of the Lord
the Lord because ultimately
you know they made the decision Jesus
chose to do it the father agreed that
this would
happen but what does it tell you what
what does it tell you the will of the
Lord was it was the will of the Lord to
crush him and then who put him to
grief um it says basically the Lord put
to
grief so that's not
Satan sat Satan wasn't the one crushing
Jesus now we have to take even one more
step back and this will be the last
thing just because
I want
to flesh this out exhaustively okay
because I'm going to show you that this
is entirely consistent go to Genesis 22
uh let me let me just interject for a
second okay although Jesus and the
father agreed to to go through with this
plan to save Humanity you know they knew
that Satan what Satan was going to do
the part that he was going to plan this
and they knew you know it's kind of like
you know just like with the the whole
thing with Adam and Eve
you know Satan was the one who got them
to sin he was in the garden that's why
God warned them hey stay away from that
tree you know don't eat that fruit
because he knew they could be subject to
the lies of Satan which they were
basically Eve was she went for it Adam
he knew better once he saw with the
fruit you know he knew better but
because he loved her he went ahead and
sin anyway you know being stupid is what
people do there's some stuff we could
get into there but I really want to keep
Drilling in on this because Isaiah tells
us that that the Lord crushed him that
the Lord laid the iniquities on him that
it was the will of God to do this which
involves father son and spirit and so
yes this gets into the plan but it
doesn't tell us that Satan crushed him
now Adventists tend to love typology so
I'm hoping that this is going to be
right up your wheelhouse last thing here
okay we're G to read about Abraham and
Isaac okay okay you're probably familiar
with the story y but let's pay very
close attention here because I want to
point something else out to you okay so
after these things God tested Abraham
and said to him Abraham and he said here
I am he said take your son your only son
Isaac whom you love and go to the land
of Mariah and offer him there as a burnt
offering on one of the mountains of
which I shall tell you so Abraham Rose
early in the morning settled his donkey
and took his his young men with him and
his son Isaac and he cut the wood for
the burnt offering and arose and went to
the place on which God had told him
on the third
day interesting that we're told that
Abraham lifted up his eyes and saw the
place from afar then Abraham said to his
young men so the men that he took with
him stay here with the donkey I and the
boy will go over there and worship and
come again to you well let's pause here
Ross what is Abraham following through
with here he's doing a Messianic
gravy but what did God tell him to go
and do what's he physically going out
and doing he's about to sacrifice his
son well then why did he say we're going
to go over there and worship and come
back to
you we got to keep reading yeah and
Abraham took the wood of the burnt
offering and he laid it on Isaac his
son and he took in his hand the fire and
the knife so they went both of them
together and Isaac said to his father
Abraham my father and he said here I am
my son
sorry he said behold the fire of the
wood but where is the Lamb for a burnt
offering and Abraham said God will
provide for himself the lamb for a burnt
offering sorry Ross that's okay I
understand so they went both of them
together when they came to the place of
which God had told him Abraham built the
altar
there and laid the wood in order and
bound Isaac his son and laid him on the
Altar and took on top of the wood then
Abraham reached out his hand and took
the the knife to slaughter his son but
the angel of the Lord called to him from
heaven and said Abraham Abraham and he
said here I am he said do not lay your
hand on the boy and do anything to him
for now I know that you fear God seeing
you have not withhold your son your only
son for me and Abraham lifted up his
eyes and looked and behold behind him
was a ram caught in a Thicket by his
horns Ross do you know what a thick it
is yeah what is it just a bunch of you
know brush Twigs you know a thorn it's a
thorn bush yeah and Abraham went and
took the RAM and offered it up as a
burnt offering instead of his son so
Abraham called the name of that place
the Lord will provide as it is said to
this day on the Mount of the Lord it
shall be
provided so Ross notice what we're
reading here we're reading a picture of
the the father taking his only son
leading him up the Mountain carrying the
wood that he will be sacrificed
on he goes away and has been told this
information I just want to start right
there carrying the wood to be sacrificed
on isn't it that's so deep right there
what correct but you have to remember
that when God tells Abraham this this is
not the first time Abraham has heard
this Abraham heard this information told
to him by God
three days
prior yes that's what it say so three
days later Abraham is going and he's
already been told what that he's going
to sacrifice his son which means I'm
sorry just you just saying that again it
just hit me like three days later how
long was Jesus's um a Ministry three
years three and a half basically yeah
and there's probably some interesting uh
interesting connection there now so it
says that this information was given to
Abraham prior to this moment right here
so in Abraham's mind he was Isaac was
already as good as dead yes and on the
third day the father received his son
back to him and the reason he told the
men the boy and I are going to go
worship and we'll be back is because
well the answer is given to us I'm going
to bring it up it's in Hebrews
11 wh mouse got out of whack here by
faith Abraham when he was tested offered
up Isaac and he who had received the
promises was in the act of offering up
his only son of whom it was said through
Isaac shall your Offspring be named so
catch this God has already told Abraham
back in Genesis 15 what in you all the
nations will be blessed and you're going
to have a son so God had already told
Abraham this
so because that was the case when it
came to Genesis 22 when he was tested
we're told he considered that God was
able even to raise him from the dead
from which figuratively speaking he did
receive him
back yes so in Abraham's mind Isaac was
already as good as gone and he knew if
God makes me follow through with this
he'll raise Isaac back from the dead
because he keeps his promises so I will
do this I I'll do it because if I have
to follow through with this and he does
die God has the power and will keep his
promise and he will raise him from the
dead the overall point though rths is
that Satan did not kill Jesus the father
did and that doesn't the father that
doesn't make the father evil because the
the son gave himself freely it was the
son's desire to do such so you'll get
these arguments from the secularist and
the atheist Etc who try and do these
things of like divine child abuse and
all that stuff does not take into that's
that's a conjecture it's it's it's
inaccurate statements made on lack of of
full information what was going on there
was a picture of the Cross of Christ so
I just wanted to comment into those
things I know that was a little bit
there but I just I hope that information
is help helpful to you um um to mention
a couple things too but go ahead I I do
get uh what you're saying there that is
true because you know even though it
doesn't seem like it we know we live in
this crazy world even Jesus said that
Satan was the basically ruler of this
world but God is in control of the
universe so he he you know it's like
I've heard to compare like Satan is
almost like a dog on a chain you know he
can only you know do so much yeah Satan
is God Satan yeah Satan is God Satan
he's Satan is not some equal no not God
like dualism like a yin and a Yang type
thing no no no way but it but I just
point out that during the time of Jesus
we read about in the gospels there was a
lot of demonic possession going on do
you think that has decreased or
increased in
2025 here is my answer and I'm gonna
give it to you from scripture
um just a
second we're gonna go actually I can
just do it on this
one so Luke 81 is actually very
important actually let me bring that up
first just so we can see
it and then hopefully it brings up
chapter 11 after that yeah so Luke 81 so
Jesus is in the middle of his
oh Jesus is in the middle of his
ministry and he says soon afterward he
went on through the cities and Villages
proclaiming and bringing the good news
of the kingdom of God
the good news of the Kingdom we often
talk about the gospel that's good news
but we often times for shorthand just
say gospel when all throughout Jesus's
Ministry he refers to it as the good
news of the Kingdom now you have to have
a little bit of understanding of of the
Old Testament Ross to understand what
the Old Testament foretold of regarding
the kingdom of God Isaiah for example
the Suter they foretell of a time where
the Messiah will come well the the
famous Christmas chapter Isaiah chapter
9 on him will the rest the the the the
government and the the increase of his
governance will know no ends Etc these
are the sort of things that were
foretold of the kingdom of God and Jesus
went about preaching the good news about
the kingdom of God as the Messiah the
foretold one now notice what he says
here in uh my mouse is getting messed up
again here gotta go down to verse 20 it
didn't didn't bring didn't bring up the
whole chapter so I did that wrong
clearly
so we got to go down to verse 20 Jesus
is in the middle let's read here about
Jesus and beel so this is the the famous
passage where basically it's being
accused that Jesus is full of demons so
now he was casting out a demon that was
mute when the demon had gone out the
mute man spoke and the people
marveled some of
them said he cast out demons by be elel
the prince of
demons While others to test him
kept seeking from him a sign from heaven
but he knowing their thoughts said to
them every Kingdom divided against
itself is laid waste and a divided
household
Falls and if Satan also is divided
against himself how will his kingdom
stand so Jesus is essentially saying
well if I'm casting out demons by the
power of Satan then why would I be doing
that that would be a house divided wh
why would Satan cast out Satan
why do you think they thought that
or who got them to think that way or
well who knows we don't know because the
text doesn't tell us now there are
varing I've heard varing theories out
there and typically the the argument
that I would align with around the why
we are speculating here but I would
argue that the why was because they did
not want to believe that Jesus was who
he said he was Jesus was considered a
troublemaker by these people which the
talmud you can get into I uh recommend
people look into what the talet has to
say about Jesus um and you'll get to see
the sort of thinking that these
individuals in Focus would have been
under the impression they would have
been under the impression this guy is
like a soothsayer this guy's a a
magician he's a he he's like a a a
necromancer he he's one of these like ma
magical you know doing something that
the Bible forbids essentially the Old
Testament scriptures forbid so that's
why I think but let's continue he says
and if Satan is also is divided against
himself how will his kingdom stand for
you say that I cast out demons by beable
and if I cast out demons by beable by
whom do your sons cast them out
therefore they will be your judges now
get this
Ross but if it is by the Finger of God
that I cast out
demons then the kingdom of God has come
upon you so Halt and then we got to read
a couple more
verses what did Jesus just say
there implicitly
he was saying that if he's casting out
demons then the kingdom of God is upon
him if he's casting out demons by the
Finger of God so the phrase Finger of
God I know in aist theology they like to
appeal to Exodus and say see the Ten
Commandments were written by the Finger
of God that is just a phrase that means
the power of God the same thing it says
was done by the uh the in in Pharaoh's
courts The Magicians who come in there
and it says um it uses that phrase the
the the Finger of God that's just a
phrase that refers to the power of God
so Jesus says if I cast out demons by
the power of God contrary to what you're
claiming then the kingdom of God has
come upon you which means the kingdom of
God was
presently there and upon the people now
this is important because of what he
goes on to say in the next verses when a
strong
man we're going to see who the strong
man is fully armed
powerful guards his own Palace his goods
are
safe but when one stronger than he
attacks him and overcomes him he takes
away his armor in which he trusted and
divides his spoils whoever's not with me
is against me and whoever does not
gather with me
scatters So my answer to your question
Ross is the reason we see less of what
we see in the biblical storyline
regarding demon possession is because
the kingdom of God is here and the
kingdom of darkness has been cast out
now I don't want to open up the can of
worms of Satan being bound I don't agree
with the Adventist theory about what
that means but I believe Satan is bound
right now due to the uh accomplished
efforts of the Lord Jesus Christ in
crushing uh Satan's kingdom and the
Lord's Prayer is essentially being
fulfilled which is also stated in the
same chapter by the way at the very
beginning um thy kingdom come thy will
be done I believe that that is happening
and the kingdom of God is gradually
expanding and Satan being a defeated foe
has been bound now and such that he does
not have the same sort of um power or
authority that he did before after being
crushed and bound so that is my answer
to your question the reason that we
don't see as much of that in the modern
day is because the kingdom of God is
here and Satan is
bound I I would actually disagree on
that just like you know like uh just
recently we had the story horrific story
about the man setting a woman woman on
fire in New York and watching her and
trying to Flame the fans I'm not saying
it doesn't happen I'm not saying it
doesn't happen I think a lot more than
what we we realize I think it's
happening every day I think it inreased
but I I I do believe like you're saying
I think when he's talking about the
strong man like if we are connected to
God there's nothing Satan can do to us
you know if you go to God if you go to
God you know Satan he's nothing to God
you know you can you know he just can
dump away whatever well right but the
the strong man here though is is the
devil yeah when a strong man fully armed
fully armed guards his own Palace the
kingdom of darkness his goods are safe
but when one stronger Jesus talking
about himself yes indeed attacks him and
overcomes him that's Christ crushing the
serpent he takes away his armor in which
he trusted and divides his
spoils so you have to understand too the
Old Testament understanding of Kingdoms
were a very common thing back then in
understanding the sort of hierarchy and
structure of a kingdom they would have
understood what Christ was saying here
as um clearly this strong man is being
referenced as somebody whose kingdom has
been overthrown essentially let's look
at two I wanna I want to look at a verse
and then uh a chapter really quickly and
then I'll I kind let you guys go move on
to other things but uh I don't think
we're in too much disagreement about a
lot of stuff but uh do you mind if do
you mind if we pause here real quick
because I know Mike has been sitting for
a long time and he has been able to say
anything I've been talking a lot I just
thought it was important I want Mike to
be able to chime in here for whatever
he's been because he's been sitting on
stuff for a while yeah yeah well I would
say just just a point of observation
while I've been listening um I do think
that this discussion is I hope for the
audience watching discussion is helpful
in the context of the great controversy
theme because the disagreement or the
dis the the the view points
diverge because of how the aenis
framework sees Satan's work happening
right now versus the kingdom that has
already come as miles has said and what
that does to the the kingdom of darkness
so because of those different views and
again this is the great controversy
theme the great controversy theme
filters through all of this stuff that
we're talking talking about in a way
that is designed to organize the
doctrines and information into a what
what Herbert Douglas says is a coherent
way of understanding everything I don't
agree with the worldview because there's
inconsistencies with scripture and I
think that's some of what miles was was
dialoguing on um so that's one thing I
would I would just kind of as a point of
observation the one thing I did want to
go to that that we kind of talked about
before um I almost feel like I don't
even remember it because it's been so
long ago since isation but Isaiah 14 and
I'm I'm just gonna I'm just going to
suggest anyone that is currently an
avenus anyone that even if you're a non
avenus and you have a concept of
Lucifer I would ask you to
please do some study on the original
language around OD star now I'm to read
a couple of things I could read multiple
articles on this okay but I'm going to
read one in particular that I find very
interesting because of its connections
to something well I'll let you make that
connection in a second so the original
language underneath here is
Hell okay it does not mean
Lucifer it literally means morning star
or day star is the way or bright shiny
object I mean it's that's the the
original now I'm going to go to
I wish I could have you pull it up I'm
going to go to an article from just so
you know where this is this is a baker
Encyclopedia of the Bible you I could
quote several articles I'm just going to
give you one and this is a this is a
Bible dictionary that is organized
topically by certain headers okay this
header is
Lucifer here's what it
reads Lucifer Appalachian
from a Latin word meaning light
lightbearer the Latin term refers to the
planet Venus appearing in the evening
and morning which is the brightest
object in the sky except for the Sun and
Moon others have identified it with the
Crescent Moon it is also said by some to
be the planet
Jupiter the Hebrew term now I want you
to understand okay what was just said is
that's the Latin
understanding okay the Hebrew term from
which the Latin Lucifer is derived is
found in the verse that we were looking
at okay this verse right here Isaiah
14:12 have you uh have you uh how have
you fallen from heaven and Morning Star
some Son of the Dawn you have been cast
down to the Earth you have once said low
the Nations that's from the NIV the word
means this is Hebrew shining
one it has cognate in
Acadian
ugaritic and Arabic those are just
semantic languages that have connections
to the Hebrew language if you're
wondering what that is the septu agent
which is the first translation of the
Hebrew Bible which is the Greek
translation of the Hebrew Bible the
targums and here we go the Vulgate which
is the Latin Vulgate which is tied to
the early um Catholic um connections the
Latin Vulgate translate is it as Morning
Star quite fitting in view of the
opposition son of the Dawn now here's
what I wanted to end
on the Hebrew expression was probably
never meant to be a
name but has come to be used thus
because the verse in which it occurs is
applied to the to Satan this apparently
was done first by Two church fathers
tulian and origin however the popularity
of Lucifer as a name for Satan may be
attributed to its use
in John Milton's Paradise
Lost
now if you if you don't know the
connection to Paradise Lost with Ellen
White's writings and the great
controversy theme there is a major
thread okay I'm not going to get into
the whole like there's a whole land you
know there's land M of stuff we could go
through but just understand that the
word here doesn't mean
Lucifer Lucifer means Morning Star it
literally means bright star now you
could you could translate that as an
understanding of well I think that's
Satan but you have to inject that into
the text especially if you look at the
text itself and if you go prior to this
what is Isaiah talking about
well he's he's he's talking about the
king of
Babylon he's using and this is what I
was saying to earlier caller he's using
a well-known idea about this
Supernatural entity that made this fall
in the Garden of Eden whoever that was
as a way of taunting and a way of of
saying see king of babyon you did the
same thing and you're gonna fall just
like this being
fell now in the great controversy theme
the way that's transmitted is
see Satan fell from heaven that's not
what Isaiah is
saying Isaiah is saying the king of
Babylon is going to fall from his high
place and he's using a
well-known uh concept about this entity
in the garden to make his case and he
claiming that to be true as a prophetic
Proclamation Isaiah is is proclaiming
this to be the future of the king of
Babylon so um just note that Lucifer
doesn't exist it's a Latin
transliteration H transliterated from
Latin means Lucifer when it's
transliterated and then two early church
fathers kind of propagated that concept
to be attached to Satan which is where
we get what what we have today so I
don't think this is I don't think his
name is Lucifer first of all I think
that's a madeup construct um but that's
a little side point to what we're
dialoguing on um so I just wanted to
kind of that's interesting yeah Ross
I'll give you the final word here I'll
give you about a minute or so we have
another guest that would like to step up
this will probably be our last guest of
the night so you can have the final word
to say whatever you would like and then
we will move on thank you so much for
being so cordial this has a great
discussion with you man thanks thanks
for thanks for coming on yeah well a
couple things I want to address that
really quickly you know um Jesus is also
referred to as the morning star and
whatever God tries to do Satan tries to
twist and counterfeit so I just want to
point that out then another thing is um
it says in here I guess if you go to um
Revelation 12 it kind of tells you or
actually 13 if I should go there it says
um it's talking about the different kind
of beasts or kingdoms the Beast is
basically a kingdom and it says here you
know it was given it's power and and
seat and Authority by the dragon who's
the dragon it's Satan so it's letting
you know that if you like you have
different kind of Kingdoms different
kind of people different kind of rulers
if you're not ruled by God who are you
ruled by it's going to be it's obviously
by default it's going to be Satan it's
now you're not it's like the old cartoon
where you had Angel and you have a maybe
a demon on your shoulder which one are
you going to listen to each day we have
to you know make a choice who are we
going to listen to is it going to be
Satan or is it g to be God it's the same
thing with Nations it's the same thing
with people and when those people went
to attack Jesus and to kill him who are
they listening to obviously not God when
they were saying crucify him crucify him
I remember I was reading a few weeks ago
where Jesus has performed a sign of
healing the man's hand and they said
show us a sign and I know Jesus like
what you know just I just showed you a
bunch of signs you should know who I am
but you know again if you're not ruled
by God you can be deceived so easily by
Satan and that's what happens to people
I think that is still happening now and
I think those people were being deceived
by Satan to say crucify him crucify him
but God the Father and Jesus already
knew how this was going to play out and
they knew they were going to overcome it
so I'll say that then also if you look
there's a uh verse there I think it's in
John where it says Satan entered into
Judas so again when je when Judas he was
there with God for three years you know
with Jesus learning from the greatest
teacher of all yet he rebelled and who
would happened he went on Lucifer's side
so I think that people are being
controlled by demons being controlled by
Lucifer if they are not submitted to
Jesus Christ
yeah and I think we would agree with
that in the generals but uh again Ross
thank you so much for being here like I
said it's been a great discussion and so
we will catch you around next time if
you uh want to come back for the next
one of these all
right all right answering anti-
Adventists uh are you a Seventh Day
Adventist yes okay are you baptized into
the Seventh Adventist
Church yes okay great we just have to
clarify that because we had one
individual earlier that decided to join
who apparently is not so just wanted to
clear that up um which uh well I guess
you can pick the direction um we'd love
to hear the biblical evidence of the
great controversy theme being
biblical well my
um my argument is not an um is it's
arguing like an ordinary Adventist not
like a theologian the general
understanding of U
what an ordinary Adventist
understands not what
the
those those difficult theological terms
and those confusing uh what but I see
you people try to come up
with um my question I have several
questions if you argue that there's no
controversy between
um well hold what what's your name sir
uh so I know so I know how to refer to
you um you can just refer to me as
LK as
what just an abbreviation LK LK okay uh
well LK the the focus of tonight is
specifically on the great controversy
world view and it being biblical so I
think the average Adventist does
understand believe some of these things
such as the point of the Cross being
about exalting God's law vindicating God
from the accusations of Satan Etc all of
these things
are hold on hold hold on hold on all of
these things are Central in Adventist
interpretation of the Bible and the
organization tells us that everything
they believe and teach comes strictly
from the Bible so on screen are just
five of many many many fun fundamental
details that are
necessary for the Adventist
interpretation across the board on
various doctrines to be true so we would
just love to see some of these things
from scripture not just the general idea
that there's a Satan and that that is an
adversary of God as herb Douglas says in
this article some may think and he's
specifically referring to seventh avenus
here that the great controversy between
Christ and Satan the fifth book in the
conflict of the ages series they may
think of that when they hear great
controversy but he says the great
controversy theme is more than a
historical survey of the battle between
Christ and Satan as traced through the
events of secular and Biblical history
so we are not contending tonight that
there's not a Satan we're not contending
tonight that there's not an adversary
who hates God Christians believe this
that this is not something that's unique
to adventism but the great controversy
is not just that it's a whole pre-earth
origin story so that's what we're
looking for biblical support
for so what is the your definition of wi
view first of all because we tend to use
a lot of that to paint it like
um like uh I mean the word view what's
what's word view what's your definition
of word view the lens through which you
see everything so for example when I was
a Seventh Day Adventist whenever
something would happen in the world
I would always filter it through this is
something taking place in this
controversy between God and Satan where
Satan is trying to diminish God's law so
for example I would view other uh you
know I would View Christian churches as
well they hate God's law because
obviously it's right there in the Ten
Commandments the seventh day Sabbath why
aren't they keeping the Sabbath oh it's
because Satan enacted this Sunday law or
he's he he enacted uh Sunday worship the
papal Sabbath through the papacy and all
these sorts of of details but all of
that stuff uh LK that's not coming from
the Bible those are details that are
coming from this pre-earth origin story
and Ellen White's writings the Bible
nowhere says that so it is a worldview
in the sense that it is the way that
seventh day Adventists are taught to
look and see the world as well as how to
read the Bible all right what do you
understand by uh like the spirit when
the spirit comes you lead you to the
whole
truth isn't it
does it mean that there is some truth
that had not been written in the
Bible Well the thesis because
because the way you you try to bring it
is like there must be like three three
word sentence the word
riew defining it because uh there are
things you can figure from The Bible for
example in your own arguments you could
be right just like the way the devil was
right when he said um if you fall down
the angels will will catch you he was
right you know all and he can can open a
hole a whole what a whole discussion of
that and defend that correctly but now
when we look at now the current what I
mean
after when Jesus says you hey I send you
the holy spirit that will tell you more
and open your minds I mean he'll tell
you more about uh
everything so you like we can't get all
the proof from the Bible you can't say
where there is they say hey this and
this and this but you can figure out
there is some there controversy because
Jesus himself say the Bible says flee
from the devil no resist the devil and
he will he will fly away so I'm I don't
know if you're getting me well no I'm
I'm getting you but if you notice the
the open Challenge on screen you kind of
just admitted our point
um and I I I appreciate your honesty I I
I seriously I'm I'm I'm floored um
because you you stated the elephant in
the room you're right this this isn't in
the Bible and that's kind of the point
and so we're frustrated um Mike and I as
well as millions of other former
Adventists um and I'm sure other
Christians out there that have heard
this stuff too and dug into it um
frustrated that this organization
consistently tells us everything they
believe comes strictly from the Bible
it's all based on the Bible
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
they say everything we believe comes
strictly from the Bible all of our
beliefs we can prove to you from the
Bible but you just admitted to us that
all these details they're not actually
there but you can read the Bible and
kind of infer and you can kind of see
well see this but my friend L okay
Mormons do the same thing and if you've
interacted with a lot of Mormons before
you'll see they do this exact thing they
just do it with the Book of Mormon they
don't do it with Ellen White's writings
they say these the same things this
stuff doesn't contradict the Bible it
just speaks about matters that the Bible
does not get exhaustive on and it gives
us better details they don't do it
oftentimes only about their prear origin
story but also about Jesus supposedly
visiting the United States uh in the
1800s in the 1900s and so um anybody can
do that so I appreciate you admitting
though that these these can't come
strictly from this stuff doesn't come
strictly from the Bible you see you are
very first to win the argument I'm
trying to make a point like you trying
to say oh mammonism you're already
grouping me with the mammonism with the
the next thing you'll be groing with
maybe Muslims or something of the oh no
I was just saying they do that same
thing I mean I'm not I'm not inry to win
the argument or anything I'm just trying
to to win the point I I've already told
you the devil would would would have won
with that argument that if he fall from
the
cliff the angels we will pick you up so
I'm not like I don't want to go into the
manism and well what I understand about
Christianity is believing in Christ not
being like Lael ammonis or anything of
the sort no no no let me stop you real
quick just to clarify the only reason I
brought up Mormonism was just to paint
you a very if you were
consistent Mormons tell me this exact
same thing that's all I'm saying and
they have a storyline where they can
point and say look none of this
contradicts the Bible
yet it contradicts claims made in the
Adventist system so you both can't be
right so my point was just that that's
not really a good standard of like well
it doesn't contradict the Bible and it
only sheds light and enhances what's
found in the Bible Well I could sit
around tonight and do that that prior to
Earth's creation Jesus was walking
around in heaven and he came across an
angel that was sitting outside of one of
the gates and this angel had an
interesting look on his face he had a
big brow Ridge he was the head of the
choir in heaven I could just start
making up all sorts of stuff that you
can't go anywhere in the Bible to
contradict that Jesus was walking around
and this Angel was outside this gate but
it's not found in the Bible so you don't
actually know this you're taking on
faith what Ellen White wrote down and
you believe it was divinely inspired and
that's fine if you want to believe that
I'm just taking umbrage with this
organization telling us everything they
believe comes strictly from the Bible
when that's not
true well
I think uh uh you are looking in the
light of the other side I mean you're
more strictly uh positioned at a
particular place not a neutral place
because when we talk
about uh like when the spirit when Jesus
says I'll give you the spirit that will
open up uh what you into the whole truth
that's already WR wait that's already
written it doesn't say the spirit is not
is not coming to say about about the
great controversy or forgive my English
but it's not it's not saying it's not
like coming to be so strictly on the
issue of I mean to be so SL so what I
mean so
narrow it's not well that text well that
text isn't referring to prophecy that
text is talking about we just looked at
this earlier that text is referring to
the spirit being sent by the father and
the son at the point of the spirit being
poured out on the disciples and the
birth of the the New Testament Church so
that's not referring to some new
revelation that's going to come where
you're going to get all this information
about a prear origin story or anything
like that Miles I think I think that's I
think that's to land it's not it's not
like it's not just that one only it's
not just just a minute I meane it's not
just you see now you are that's why I
have issues with the discussing
sometimes uh in this strictly
positioned channels because you just now
now you're just trying to coil around
that one the other verses that we say
the same unto us the spirit has
reveals reveals what is hidden to to to
what I mean un to us yeah that's that's
that's the illumination of the Holy
Spirit yes yes yes it reveals some other
things that are not that are hidden so
what is hidden is not in the it's not
necessarily in the Bible
strictly see like like the great
controversy if well it could be part of
that was is hidden in the Bible it's
still in the Bible we can still get um
you can't I don't think Adventist just
came from home and imposed a great no
they came through the Bible understood
the Bible and they had their own
understanding that there must be mean
controversy
between what uh the devil and Christ
that's why even even Christ himself
says the devil is the ruler of this
world we don't expect us Christians
living in this world whom the ruler is
not Christ the is the Devil Himself and
you expect to be have a freelance like
you have everything that's why there is
a lot of issues around the Christian
churches that's why you are so divided
that's why they I mean the the world is
not is in a mess I mean well I would
argue adventism is actually in a bigger
mess of division than the Christian
church is but that is a topic of a topic
for another another time um oh yes okay
the I engage with I engage with
thousands of seventh day Adventists
every year and I'm just being honest
with you my friend seventh day adventism
is by far one of the most divided groups
groups out there defitely and we expect
that because of what even the I mean the
church had their own division they had
their own problems that's why well well
hold up though the great controversy
theme is supposed to keep you guys
immune from that you're not supposed to
be part of
Babylon supposed to be if if Jesus if
Jesus himself had a what a
Judas how how we supposed to be immune
from uh what from from uh the devil's I
mean the devil's attack is right but my
friend in chapter 14 of your guys's
fundamental beliefs book on the unity in
the church your organization tells us
that there is not supposed to be
disagreements around the core pillar not
supposed to be right correct and if
there is then you guys fit your own
definition of Babylon that's why the
great controversy theme is supposed to
give you immunity from that you just
admitted not only that the doesn't come
strictly from the Bible but that
adventism fits its own definition for
Babylon no no no the problem with you is
you want to win the argument for your
post or something but I'm trying to make
a
point any discussion what you want is
you rush so much to winning arguments
I've seen your name most of the time but
if you really honest with the with the
discussions you would see the points not
not just to score some
goals because I'm just responding to
claims that you're making from your own
your own source how do you expect Jesus
had 12 disciples how do you expect
them I mean 12 disciples who I mean how
do you expect like Jesus had 12
disciples one of them and even told them
one of them is a devil you look at even
the after
after after you look at for example
Peter Peter himself was so weak he would
promise to follow Jesus but at the end
of the day when when the when there's a
lot of what when there's enough
Temptation he would fall back so how do
you expect us to and like Advent Church
to be so so perfect such that when we
promise something we have a our
own we have our own beliefs that our we
believe our Bible best and they have
good intention and they are
straightforward but we have individual
Adventists you don't expect all of us to
be strictly thinking the same thing and
the same line they must be follow there
must be fallouts they must be like you I
mean people who come and then they
Justus daugh of that story of where the
S through some what through some seeds
some some will grow they they'll grow a
bit then they'll die some will become
malignant like you some will will will
will what some will grow up to the very
end so we don't expect that because of
it would be very I mean the devil has to
fight us we have for for there to be for
the you to be a true church there must
be some I mean the devil cannot be
comfortable with you we can't have I
mean
Highway we have to have bumps that's
what I see well LK I look forward to the
day that you leave the avenus church
because it sounds like you're already on
that path because you're making the
exact same claims I do I I agree with
you completely the SDA church should
stop making these grandiose crazy claims
that are easily falsifiable which is
exactly the point I'm saying you're
agreeing with me you're saying we're all
gonna have you know disagreements Etc
and you're recognizing yeah theology is
complex Etc well then this organization
shouldn't be making these laughable
claims that they have the theological
God Particle the equivalent of The
Theory of Everything it brings coherence
allegedly to all biblical subjects they
didn't Discover it it was given to them
yes that's their words that's not me
bringing this charge this is an insane
claim and when you make a claim at this
level yes you're going to come under the
spotlight other okay Christians
Christians aren't making this sort of
claim we're not claiming these grandiose
things I could be wrong in all sorts of
areas and I recognize that and I'm sure
I am because theology goes deep it
depends how deep we go into a Doctrine
and how nuanced the doctrine is but your
organization's the one making these
grandio claims and it sounds like you're
even recognizing eh these aren't exactly
true now I want to pause here real quick
because Mike has been sitting quietly
for quite some time so let's let him
chime in here and you guys can go back
and forth I'm just going to turn my or
my my camera off so you guys can
interact and I don't want to keep
interjecting let me just say a couple of
things um and the the first thing would
be this isn't just um a claim if you go
and I can't bring it up on on the screen
but if you go to the the avenus SDA
beliefs website um and just unless you
have the B the actual book itself uh
belief number eight is called the Great
controversy yes um and if you read from
again you could find it in the book but
if I'm just on the website the very
first couple of links this will cover
the first thing is is how the great
controversy began so forget for a second
what Herbert Douglas is saying on the
screen I agree that this is what
Adventists believe but the great
controversy theme begins with the war in
heaven like this this is this is a part
of the fundamental teachings of the
Adventist Church and here's
you see wait wait a minute sometimes
when you say there's war in heaven
hang I hope I'm not interrupting you s
yeah let let me finish real quick if
you're a baptized Adventist your
baptismal vows make you say that you
agree that this is true now you might
not live it out you might not whatever
but in order to be a baptized Adventist
member you have to believe all 28 of
those beliefs and claim that they are
true
exactly so so this has to be a part of
your Paradigm as an Adventist you can't
just say ah I don't know I mean maybe
kind of just kind of in this battle it's
articulated by the Adventist Church and
I think Herbert Douglas is correct in
stating that the reason number eight
fundamental belief is there is because
in adventism it has to be there in order
to make whole system
coherent I'm not disputing that and
sometimes when you guys say like
Adventist believe it looks like it's
something horrible it's not even in the
Bible you people you never say that the
Bible says there was war in heaven
that's something that you'll never claim
because you are supposed to paint the
Adventist like in the world view the
world has to see the Adventist as very
shameful people who believe that are not
in the Bible we are saying the Bible
says there was war in heaven and we
believe that the Adams fall was the
devil had something to do with it Adam
did not just fall because of he wanted
to he was convinced okay so
let let me finish let me finish let me
finish let me finish let me just finish
a bit because we believe that Adam I
mean Adam was convinced by the devil who
had already fallen from
I don't think he came back and went back
to Heaven no we believe that he that ad
and Eve wait a minute let me just finish
this one we believe that Adam was
convinced by the devil
that you still there oh Elk's audio went
out Mike you can chime back in there
until his audio comes back well I just
my my response is like where is the
claims that he's saying where is it in
the Bible I know that this is what
avenus teach but if you go to like the
eighth fundamental belief you know the
great controversy begins in heaven okay
show me that in scripture where does it
say like you if you can put on the
screen the five claims that we were kind
of trying to
address um this specifically is part of
the Great controversy theme the
worldview and it require Ires that the
jealousy that happened with Satan was
because Jesus was given the
authority that Satan
wanted and he became jealous because of
the authority that that's where it all
came from and because of that that's the
attack that Satan began on the Ten
Commandments that were also in heaven
prior to the creation like all this
stuff so don't like if you come on the
show and you're like don't just say you
know you guys are just making stuff up
and making it difficult all this stuff
what no this is like go read your own
fundamental beliefs
guys don't calm me on here saying like
we're making these claims and we're
trying to make you all look bad we don't
have to do that your beliefs do it for
you yeah well and Mike it's it's kind of
a good example too there there's
something else that he said and I
understand practically
speaking why he would say this but he
said I he I'm paraphrasing but he
started off by essentially saying I'm
not here to get into all that real
theological stuff I want to talk about
this on the lay level and LK if you hear
this he dropped by the way I think
something messed up on his end it wasn't
him being kicked um I think that is a
perfect picture of the problem is that
and I've said this for a long time folks
you can go back in the archives and you
can look and look and look and I've said
this repeatedly the average Seventh Day
Adventist does not know that they've
been equipped with these things they
think the stuff is biblical now
thankfully this guy was willing to even
at least recognize well it doesn't all
come from the Bible Well it doesn't all
come from the Bible um of course not but
we can deduce and we can you know do
these sorts of things um but at the end
of the day the average Seventh Adventist
has not
been told clearly and plainly that by
being taught seventh day adventism
you're not just being taught another
like if you're a Lutheran or a calvinist
Lutheran and Calvinists do not have
different World Views they have
different systematic
theologies where they agree about 95% of
things you get into the nitty-gritty
where they disagree one side agrees with
predestination the other side agrees
with predestination but you have to dig
deeper than that to see where they
disagree so of course there are areas
amongst Christians where there are
disagreements even Protestants and
Catholics yet Protestants and Catholics
don't have a different world view we
have the same world view and then we
disagree around things like mechanics
how is the Lord Jesus Christ present in
the Eucharist or is he present at all we
disagree on finer details on things Etc
and we argue over scripture and um some
parties are willing to say well we
should give precedent to older
understandings of people that are closer
to the apostles Etc but the argument is
ultimately over scripture and we're
focusing on the the grammar Linguistics
these sorts of things that's not how it
functions in
adventism in adventism you are equipped
with a world view and that world view
comes with a Systematic Theology this is
why the gospel in adventism is seen as
Systematic Theology when you ask an go
back folks and look at Open Mic number
one and number two okay this is number
five go back and look at number one and
number two which had to do with change
my mind that the Adventist Church has a
false god and a false god gospel and
listen to the individuals that came onto
this platform and sought to defend or
change my mind Etc on those subjects
what you're going to find is that they
can't just tell you the gospel simply
one individual went on a long thing I
would I let them go for about 10 minutes
before I had to interject they went on a
long thing about the sanctuary seven
steps through the sanctuary this long
convoluted thing where Thy Thy way oh
God is in the sanctuary Psalm 77 and so
from there jumping to here and it was
this long complex
thing that's not the gospel the gospel's
not Systematic
Theology but I think this guest gave a
perfect example Mike of how Adventists
are equipped with this lens but
oftentimes aren't even aware of it
because what he deemed to be things that
were oh that's you know all the
theological stuff that all the scholars
deal with but not the lay people yet
he's defending all this stuff he he's
ultimately trying to argue it he's just
saying well okay they're not all in the
Bible all the details aren't in the
Bible but they can be supported by the
Bible so he does believe these things
but appears to not recognize that he's
actually been equipped with this
worldview and and I wish so I get it
because I've been more recently out so I
understand
the the challenge because you're
equipped with this idea that your
version of or your interpretation of the
truth is the remnant truth it is the
perfect truth and so you're you're
almost armed with this idea that
everyone else is wrong and so it doesn't
really matter what's brought to you you
can just push it aside because our
worldview is is is the right worldview
um but the pro the problem with that is
that it doesn't allow the individual to
actually check it with
scripture like that's the challenge so I
have yet to hear anyone please show me
in scripture where it says prior to the
creation of the
world say like all this stuff happened
show me and and no one has been able to
articulate that here's why here's what I
want an AVST an honest AVST to say
because it's not in the
Bible like just be honest it's not in
the Bible it's in in Ellen White's
writings That's Where It's At guys but
just be
honest yeah and Mike that's that's kind
of part of my um I'm getting ready to to
do a video here I don't know if it's
going to be this month or next month but
um it's gonna be titled something like
am I angry um I'm gonna give it's been a
minute since I've done this there's a
lot more people that um are are
consuming the content on this platform
now who maybe haven't heard this stuff
so I'm going to kind of give an overview
of why I take the approach that I do in
certain contexts and why I can come
across pretty abrasive and kind of like
a fire brand sometimes but in that is
exactly what you just said there one of
my biggest pet peeves about this
organization is that they won't own
their beliefs it drives me crazy when
any group does this I've done Street
evangelism for almost a decade at this
point and there are a handful of groups
out there Mormons I've mentioned them a
couple times they oftentimes will do the
same thing no no no brother we believe
in the Trinity we believe the same thing
you do and then I'll quote to them from
their own source documents okay well
what about Joseph Smith here who's
literally anathematizing such and saying
all these churches are false they're all
apostate and it was their duty to
restore the church that fell away they
have a f their Creeds and their
confessions are an Abomination is what
he says well our our Christian Creeds
put forth what we believe about who God
is so you guys don't well and then they
start defending it well hold on now
friend why didn't you just own own that
at the beginning just own it just own it
don't do this silliness of like no no
brother we believe the same thing no the
Adventist Church outright States they're
The Remnant you need to join their
church if you want to be saved you risk
Eternal salvation if you don't keep the
seventh day Sabbath as they've defined
and all these other things just own it
and then we can move on to actually
discussing those things but at the same
time they try to do this whole we just
believe the Bible we're bullish on the
Bible the Bible the Bible the Bible yet
like we heard from this last guest it's
not there it's all not there this whole
prear origin narrative is the lens by
which the Bible is read and I've used
the example of the cross a number of
times tonight that's just one example
yeah why did Jesus come supposedly
having a sinful nature like we have but
he didn't sin they claim at least the
the Orthodox by the book you know
they'll say well that's last generation
theology yeah AKA Ellen White it's like
m
was getting this from Ellen White not
just his own vain imaginings but that
doctrine that you apparently repudiate
if you're a Neo Adventist that's coming
from Ellen White and it's informed by
the great controversy theme he had to
have a sinful nature why because if not
then Satan's accusations essentially
can't truly be silenced because Jesus
wasn't exactly like we are which means
uh there's not the example set that we
can keep the law and and all that sort
of stuff so it's all f filtered through
this stuff it's not coming from the
Bible yeah I I agree I'm I'm I'm
comically watching the the chat as as
you're yeah well let's let's uh let's
get a couple questions here Bible Vibes
she's an Adventist um she says you guys
think Jesus sinned how friend how did
you get that conclusion where did I say
that of course not Jesus was the
antitypical Passover Lamb spotless
blemish free of course not we would
never claim that I was explaining how in
last generation theology which is really
just by the book Seventh Adventist great
controversy theology the claim is is
that Jesus came with a sinful nature but
he didn't sin we weren't objecting to
that that Jesus didn't sin we're
objecting to Jesus coming with a sinful
nature no he didn't have a sinful nature
you can't have a sinful nature and not
be a sinner that's a fundamental
misunderstanding of what it means to
have a sinful nature but furthermore um
Jesus is not in the Fallen progyny of
Adam he's the second Adam so he doesn't
come in the Fallen line of Adam this is
why the Virgin birth which we're going
to get uneasy now for a lot of
Adventists here Mike this might make you
uncomfortable as well um but this is why
the doctrine partially I understand has
christological implications as well but
this is why the doctrine of the
theotokos that Mary's the mother of God
the god-bearer is an important Doctrine
and the Virgin birth is such an
important thing so no we weren't saying
that at all at all
let's see what else we got over here and
I'll let you chime in Mike I know there
was one other question man we've gotten
so many comments up here it's hard to
keep up with all of it let me know if
you see something that um you'd like to
potentially address um I've seen it
several times I don't even know where it
is um something about the Sunday law
you'll see when the Great controversy
theme is V great controversy theme will
be true when the Sunday law happens yeah
we're doing a stream on that in two
weeks by the way that's another example
like this is again this is another
example of there is nowhere in
scripture where it says anything about
Sunday keeping
Christians waking havoc and killing
Adventists like this is a horrible
Doctrine
horrible I mean it's it it's so
disjointed to the body of Christ to
think that that's going to happen that
that that Sunday keeping
Christians are going to somehow
Slaughter and kill Sabbath Keepers over
a day it's also slander Mike it's also
slander and bearing false witness and
violating the Ten Commandments and and
it's not even under and unfortunately it
doesn't even understand the Crux of like
what each side believes like it doesn't
even it doesn't even it just shows the
lack of theological depth people have
inside of the Adventist Church they just
have been sold a bill of goods yep Mike
we are doing I brought this comment out
from Dave Dave Dave Herer Dave I really
am going to encourage you to tune in on
January 20th inauguration day where
we're going to be doing a project 2025
stream this is going to be a big year on
answering adventism for this specific
topic since 2025 is here and Donald
Trump won Dave I highly encourage you to
tune into that stream um because we will
address all of the project 25 hysteria
there but ironically enough ironically
enough Mike guess what passage of
scripture is appealed to in the the
individual we're going to use the
Seventh Adventist we're going to use to
uh listen to and interact with guess
what scripture he uses to support the
Sunday
law Isaiah 14 oh my word he says the
individual we're going to be looking at
says Isaiah 14 puts forth a fstep plan
of Satan's plan to enact the Sunday
law so so Miles you remember when I when
I said to you this concept of of narc
Jesus this like every get read in the
scripture where every part of scripture
is about the Adventist whatever you it's
yeah yeah Chris Roseboro uses that
phrase I don't know if he coined that or
not he's been using that for like a long
time I probably probably a decade I'm
just saying I don't know if he
originated that or not but but it's a
perfect way to describe a number of of
theologies out there for those that do
not know Nara Jesus is a term that is
used to refer to when a person
constantly reads themsel into the Bible
and yes the Sunday law is a perfect
example of Nara Jesus it's it's
apparently all over the Bible it's all
over Revelation it's in Isaiah it's all
over the place and it's specifically
referring to 7th Day Adventists and them
eventually getting persecuted because
all throughout the Bible present truth
apparently is just everywhere in the
Bible referring to the Seventh Day
Adventist classic case of of Nara
Jesus Mike is last thing and this I'm
gonna do a Shameless plug for a second
um someone just mentioned in the in the
chat you're like I propose that Mike
gives a description of Revelation 127
to13 which I think is funny AVST are
fixated on Revelation I get it uh it's
ingrained um yeah if if any of you are
interested this is going to be happening
this year if anyone is interested go to
the thinking cup.com get familiar with
that particular website that's where I
write articles um but I am going to be
launching an entire walkth through from
beginning to end of Revelation from a
very different perspective so to whoever
this Morton guy is if you're interested
in my view of that you probably should
check it out and pay attention when that
launch is coming in the next I don't
know couple of weeks months so well cool
brother um um thank you for sharing that
thank you for letting people know and
thank you folks for being here this was
a phenomenal phenomenal night thank you
to all the Seventh Adventist I I
sincerely mean that even the guy who
joined who was part of the seven Monon
7th Day Messianic Church of the West
downtown or whatever it was that he said
um thank you as well for for joining I I
I've not heard of that sect um so I'm
going to have to watch back on this I'm
glad we have it on record so I can start
looking into that more and write some
articles on our website about this and
study upon the history might make for
some good content in the future but
nevertheless thank you all so much for
being here as well as the guests that
showed up we will definitely be doing
more of these in 2025 and there'll be
some solo ones and we'll do some more
guest appearance ones as well but may
Christ richly bless you in the grace and
peace won by him and his vicarious death
on the cross for Sinners until next time
God bless
[Music]